all right guys
bang bang i've got dave here you ready
pop i'm in miami
in florida a free city and a free state
i'm very excited are you gonna move here
eventually
well we've just moved my company down
here we moved locals here uh
i'm thinking about it i sat down with my
business managers and i know you know a
little something about dollars and cents
and they basically looked at me and
were like you're an idiot for living in
los angeles and uh
i mean in effect we crunch the numbers i
could live for free
you know what i mean like my every no
matter what i bought here i would in
essence
be living for free i'm a little you know
the humidity
my hair is a little lower here i got to
do like just the tighter cut like you
then i would be all right that's that's
the main thing keep it no i
i have to get here at some point like
what is going on in miami
is just extraordinary yeah like
literally you sent out a tweet
something about locals and then the
mayor tweeted at me and now i'm here to
interview him tomorrow like
that's so the reverse of the bananas
[ __ ] that i'm living through in la
where i hate the mayor and hate the
governor
so it's like yeah i think i got it then
maybe the governor's like breaking the
law in california
i want that man in jail that gavin
newsom is an evil disney cartoon villain
who should be
in jail just i mean i know you know but
like the french laundry thing alone
should have taken him down all right so
let's just start with
uh a topic that i know that we've talked
about before which
is politicians for the most part have
this like
immunity to criminal charges or
uh the legal system there is social
pressure
which we saw some of that happen uh over
the last year or so
but the actual like checks and balances
of our democracy that are supposed to
hold people accountable for
doing things that are legal versus not
legal they just don't
apply if you are in certain political
offices and so like
let's just start is that like just a
perfect example of
how the whole system's screwed up yeah
that's a great place to start because
basically what you're saying is nothing
works anymore and that's
we're kind of in the show must go on
version of democracy at this point like
everyone knows
it's not working but we got to keep
pretending it's working because
otherwise we'd really have to look in
the mirror and be like what what are we
right now is it what are we well i would
say we're basically a
somewhat functioning democracy at some
level at this point but
it's very tenuous right now like there
are so many things that are upside down
right now like
like it could basically turn like this
like they could pack the courts
they could change the electoral college
these are not things that i'm making up
these are things that they're saying
that the lefties basically
are saying they want to do and then it's
like the game really is over on top of
the fact of all the stuff that you're
always talking about relative
to finances and everything else it's
like does anyone really trust
that these things make sense that your
money is insured
that the banks aren't just gonna
collapse like it all feels
kind of crazy right now and what sucks
is we don't have trusted voices like how
many people
when you wake up in the morning and
you're scrolling twitter like usually
and these you follow people by choice
but usually i'm like man that guy's an
idiot and this is a [ __ ] and that's a
sellout and this is a grifter
and it's like it's really hard to find
people that are basically trustworthy
i'm not saying they get everything right
but just like ballpark estimate of like
where we're at where we've been where
we're going it's really i'm trying to be
that for some people and i think i have
been but it doesn't mean i'm right all
the time
but we've lost that trusted group it's
just almost completely gone
i think that there's three groups of
people that
are trusted in the sense of if they're
good at what they do
there's a reason why they're trusted one
is macro
hedge fund investors all they think
about all day long is risk
yeah and they think about complex
systems and then they
wager money if they're right they make
money if they're wrong they lose money
it's the ultimate skin and they can
always get bailed out one way or another
so that's some of them yeah
but for those folks uh there's this
natural
sense of you can't [ __ ] the
actual asset going up or down it's gonna
do it with or without you and therefore
for the most part
your money being wagered you have to
think a certain way right you have to
seek truth
there's basically some sense of reality
there yeah you can't just make up the
whole thing right yes yeah
the second group is uh what i will call
the silicon valley uh
outcast and so what i mean by that is
not
all silicon valley investors not all
silicon valley founders because i think
some of them are the worst offenders of
a lot of this stuff
but the folks that uh are well respected
in silicon valley
but definitely are a little kind of
they're
they're they're kind of out there like i
don't know if i want to do deals with
them
you know one let's take like a founder's
fund yeah uh hereticon
was a conference that they were gonna
put on yes i was
i was at one of the meetings discussing
what was gonna happen there so like
those people obviously aren't very
worried about what other people think
about them yeah they're here to
take a path that is not well worn yeah
so i think that like there's
i like a lot of those guys well they're
seeking of truth
right you may agree with them disagree
with them whatever like they're they're
trying to head into direction so i think
that that's it
and then the third one is like what i'll
call like pure independence
and one of the uh one of the people that
recently
has gone from and maybe once i wasn't
paying attention before
and now just i have been or i don't know
why
glenn greenwald feels like he came out
of nowhere
from i'm a journalist to like i've taken
every weapon out and i am ready for
battle
every day yeah and he's going after
people and he's doing all stuff i'm kind
of reading i'm like
the guy's not wrong well i will pat
myself on the back
a little bit here which by saying he's
kind of repeating a lot of the stuff
that i was saying
four years ago from from a political
perspective because i was a lefty too so
glenn
if you think of glenn he's like a
traditional lefty and i think what does
that mean
well he's a lefty in that he
if you look well so first off i would
say we shouldn't look at things
left and right anymore you should look
at things as sort of top bottom that you
should look at them as
you know you're either for centralized
power or decentralized power so
that would be the basic thing but in a
traditional sense lefty meaning you're a
democrat you believe the government
should and can do certain things or
you're more of a conservative or
republican and that you basically
believe the government's not supposed to
do a lot
don't tread on me low taxes states
rights things like that so he definitely
comes from more of like
centralized democratic that's right so
he comes from that world
okay i come from that world too then i
woke up very publicly over the last
couple years that's kind of what put me
on the map
and he was sort of staying in that spot
and then i think what happened
and the re and this is where i think you
woke up to him
was trump and what he realized was and i
think a lot of lefties realized this is
that trump was not
this evil right-wing crazy monster that
they made him out to be in many respects
he was doing a lot of the things that we
all wanted let's get us out of wars
let's not pay
countries to do things that often work
against our interests
let's get rid of regulation let's try to
get the economy going so a lot of
economic populists that were on the left
started liking trump so i think
and then what for for glenn that i think
really cut close to him
was to watch people that pretend that
they're journalists but they're actually
journalists
to watch them basically all day long
nitpick every little sentence with trump
and suddenly take all the reverse
positions they used to
that's really what i think like blew it
up for him and then and then he really
has gone in that direction but we've
seen a lot of people in our world
kind of go in that direction since where
i would say they're now
in effect i would say they're
libertarians basically
they're old school liberals at some
level i but really
you're woke or conservative is sort of
what i would say at this point doesn't
mean you're conservative like in the way
we all think of like a traditional
conservative
like i think i know most of your
political views but like i don't like
off the top of my head i don't know if
you're pro
choice or not let's see but i would say
you're conservative either way in a
certain sense like nobody really wants
to hear that because the word is kind of
scary and then people think you're mean
or something like that
but that's what it is if you wanna if
you want america to continue in some way
if you respect freedom and individual
choice and any of those things
i would say in essence you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're you're you're you're whatever
it's capitalism it's individualism
it is uh personal responsibility crazy
stuff right
very scary ideas we should actually stop
talking
what was it for you that kind of woke
you up in terms of
when you talk about like being a denver
because i think that's one of the things
that most people
uh they use is like the the mud slinging
against people who have views that you
or i may have
uh they would say oh you've always been
that way like you're the hardcore right
but you actually was a bernie supporter
i was a bernie you can see
videos i'm not proud of them but you can
see videos of me in like 2015.
i agree with bernie on everything and
the thing is with the lefties and the
progressives have done this really well
everything they say
kind of sounds right unless you think
about it for two seconds
like it all sounds right in that initial
thing like 15 minimum wage well of
course it sounds right like yes we want
poor people
or people on the lower end of the
economic class to make more money that
sounds right but then there's no
economic theory behind that you can't
just artificially
tell businesses that they have to pay
people this much blah blah blah and then
of course you're just picking a number
so why not 20 why not 30.
by the way rashida talib you know one of
the progressives in in the
house she's pushing for 20 and sometimes
25
and it's like well yeah why i guess
she's more moral than than old bernie
well
the government is just going to print it
all so then the business owners won't
have to pay
it they'll print it all so that's the
other thing that they do i'll get back
to the question a sec but they they
print it all and then at the same time
they always want to raise taxes so then
what's the purpose of raising taxes
other to
otherwise than punishing people you know
what i mean if they believe they can
just print print print print
well then why would you need to be
raising taxes unless you're actually
trying to punish
the producers at the same time my
favorite statistic in
all of the government conversation
politics economics etc
2011 i think or was 2009 i can't
remember but
since 2009 or 2011 the u.s federal
government
has taken in more federal income tax
every single year than the year prior so
for
a decade every year they've collected
more right they've made more money
from a revenue standpoint at the exact
same time
every single year the inter year deficit
yeah
has widened that is not anything
right it's not that's so that's the
first part that's what lefties never
want to hear about that it's not an
income problem oh if we just gave them
more education we need just more money
for teachers
it's like no because if any of that ever
worked
then education would be getting better
but is anyone in california like boy we
really have a great
public education over here uh but to
answer your question directly there were
a couple moments that really left
starkly and i think for a lot of lefties
you need to be like literally like
basically hit in the head with a frying
pan to realize what's going on because
it's so
it's so much part of your ethos like if
you just if you grow up in america from
a cultural perspective you're a lefty
right like it's like democrats are good
liberals are nice republicans are mean
and care about money and war so you
really have to be like whacked with
something so one
one moment was when did you get whacked
when did i get i got waxed i got whacked
a couple times but one of them i'll give
you
was uh i was on air with the young turks
and their far left progressive network
when i was one of them
and they're playing a video of this guy
david webb do you know david webb he's a
serious xm
host conservative so he's a fox news guy
also
he's a conservative who happens to be
black okay so you can already see where
this is going
and they're watching they're playing a
clip of him and they're calling him an
uncle tom
and a self-hating black man and you know
just all of the worst
stuff you could possibly say about
somebody what they didn't know was i had
had a show years before on siriusxm and
i used to see david in the hallway and i
would go on his show
i was a lefty he was on the right we'd
battle it out and then we'd go
downstairs to del frescos and have steak
and have whiskey and have a great time
we became great friends he's still a
good friend of mine to this day
and i'm sitting there watching them and
i'm thinking wait a minute wait a minute
i know david webb i know this is a good
man i know he believes what he believes
he fights for what he believes he's
he's put himself out there it's not easy
to say i'm a black conservative it's
like saying i'm a gay conservative or
whatever else
and here you have the so-called tolerant
people
saying all the worst things you can
possibly say about a black man
and they're doing it in the name of
tolerance you know what i mean they're
oh you black man
you don't behave the way we want black
people to behave you're a bad guy
and suddenly in that moment because i
knew him it wasn't just like a guy i was
seeing on a tv screen is it fair to call
him a friend
yeah he's a very good friend of mine but
so here i have they're saying all the
worst things in the world about a friend
of mine who i know
is forthright and honest and then it hit
me it was like
you guys call everybody else racist but
you're the racist
because what is racism prejudice
prejudge
well they see a black man and by the
color of that black man's skin they
think oh black man must think these
things
black men allowed to think these things
and i i literally remember looking at
them like looking at my other panelists
and it hit me i was like these are the
racists and then once you realize that
that they're looking at the world
through a prism that is that is
very very backwards pretty much the rest
falls apart so that's the beauty of the
red pill thing
if you can get someone to have their red
pill moment whatever it is
the others you only need to have one red
pill moment the other now some people
snort it right so some people
that's what i told i told candace owens
i told candace owens she like crushed it
up and stored it and then she was gone
like she was a lefty she snored it and
then bam she's like supporting trump
like that
that's not how most people do it most
people it's like a slow release
little time release kind of thing and it
can literally take years
but once the process starts it started
it's like neo in the matrix like he
didn't want to see it the second he saw
it
but once you see it it affects
absolutely everything in your life
that was moment one what was the next
major one that you remember
um so there were there were two others
i'll give you one other which which
actually happened right before but this
was the one that that like fully
that started the process so i probably
should have done this one first
uh i was watching real time with bill
maher and did you ever see this there's
a very famous episode when sam harris
was on with ben affleck and they were
talking about radical islam
do you remember this okay so basically
you live in a world that i don't really
understand that well so i'm going to get
an education today
no no we're both going to get an
education so um
so sam was on the show you know when
bill does a show he does the panel so
there's three people on the other side
and they're doing like hot topics
and then you know he does like a
protected interview at the end of the
show where it's just you and bill right
so sam was on that side of the table so
it was really supposed to just be sam
and bill going back and forth bill maher
biggest lefty liberal in america for the
last 20 years
and sam harris who i didn't even know
who he was at the time but this
mild-mannered
you know nice suit very soft-spoken
neuroscientist talking about inner peace
he was on a book tour for a book called
waking up a guide to spirituality
without religion so this was not
someone that was coming on the show to
fight with people anyways
bill obviously not a fan of religion
right and sam is like sort of the most
well-known atheist
in in america they start talking about
religion and and ben
affleck who was about to do batman for
the first time and he was very jacked up
i don't know if it was all natural
just saying he was like huffing and
puffing and red in the face
they started talking about islam and
basically sam said
that you should be allowed to criticize
any set of ideas but you don't want to
be bigoted towards people and we all
know this to be true
of course you could criticize the the
platform of the republican party that
doesn't mean you hate all
republicans right separate the person
from the idea simple as that so you
could criticize the old testament it
doesn't mean you hate all jews
and in this case sam was saying well you
should be able to criticize the ideas of
the quran but you don't want to be
bigoted towards muslims
everyone gets that it's it's it's such a
it's well i can't say everyone gets it
obviously everyone doesn't get it but
but it's a fundamental if you want to be
like a truly honest person in the world
it's a
fundamental thing that you must
understand affleck went bananas on the
two of them and the line that blew up
was he he said to bill maher and to sam
harris
you're gross and racist and he was
screaming and huffing and puffing and
pounding the table
and suddenly so i should have told you
this story first because when you're
talking about that wake-up moment the
next day basically
so i'm watching this and i'm going whoa
this this gets to what i've been trying
to piece together you know when you're
thinking something for a long time and
then something happens
and then like the legos come together
and that's what it was like because i
was like this is what
the progressives do with everybody they
keep telling you that decent people
bill maher no one in their right mind
thinks bill maher's a racist
you can think whatever you want about
bill maher i don't think anyone honestly
thinks he's a racist
and here's this neuroscientist talking
about you know inner peace
but suddenly bill uh in effect affleck
thinks he has the right to just call
them racist without
think about what it would be like in a
conversation if you just met somebody
like it would take a while before you
told them that they were racist right
but like within two minutes he sits down
and they're racist
and then what i watched happen over the
next couple days suddenly everybody huff
po
vox all the lefty things suddenly all
these articles bill maher's a racist
ben affleck called bill maher a racist
he's a racist sam harris is a racist
and once i saw that i realized how the
framing was completely backwards there's
a set of people who are trying to talk
about extremely difficult things
you could argue that that might be the
most difficult because you're talking
about religion you're talking about
islam terrorism all these things
that might be the most hard thing to
talk about and there's a sliver of
people
trying to talk about it honestly and
what is your reward
from the lefties the reward is your
racist now i'll just say one other thing
on that which is
that bill maher who has been the
standard bearer of the left
for 20 almost 30 years in america at
this point you know he was doing
politically incorrect before that
people on the right like bill maher now
people on the left hate bill maher why
because he defends free speech he
defends free speech so people on the
right basically are like bill maher
you're a lefty
you don't really get it we disagree with
you on abortion we disagree with you on
taxes blah blah blah
but you defend free speech and that's so
important to us that basically people on
the right if you say to the average
conservative what do you think about
bill maher
they'll be like ah you know he's okay i
disagree with him on some stuff but he's
okay
you ask the average like lefty foot
soldier msnbc person what they think
about bill maher he's a racist
and and that fundamental disconnect is
is so
it's so intertwined with what's wrong
with the left right now
is there like a central
viewpoint right like i i i think it's
something crazy
yeah and this is me coming from somebody
who uh i understand very little about
politics
uh i like to think no but you get first
principles which is more important
maybe i uh that would be a kind thing
you just say to me but well politics is
a game you get the philosophy behind it
yeah freedom which i think is good
and so i it to me it's like uh there's
the labels and like all this kind of
stuff and if you kind of strip all that
away
it feels like okay you have two groups
of people they have different views
about all these different topics
uh but naturally it's like uh almost
like a bell curve
yeah like is there some people in the
middle who are just like you know what
like
i think a i don't feel super strong
about it right like it's not like i'm
like an extremist in that end
by the way if you show me some
information and data and i might change
my mind a little bit and like move a
little bit more you know
the left or the right or whatever but
like that central piece it almost feels
like that's like either
disappeared or just like they're like
nope i'm not participating like i'm
gonna
shut the hell up and i'm getting out of
here yeah well that's partly what
happened that's partly a function of
social media because
if you're in the center let's say well
then you're gonna get
hit from both sides and that's nobody
wants neither one of the extremes like
the center because they're not on their
side
because it's like well at this point i
would say as i define things before
where you're sort of woke or
conservative i would say the center
the center is if you think that the
constitution is decent that the founding
of america
i'm doing this all from an american
perspective let's say if you think the
founding of america was good
if you think individual rights are good
if you think rule of law is good the
bill of rights are good that we have
god-given rights so the government
didn't give us rights
it can protect them and then whether we
agree on marginal tax rates or the
estate
tax or the wealth tax or even abortion
or any of those other things are
irrelevant so that's the fight right now
so i would say
most almost everybody except
that the except the anti foot soldiers
that are literally burning down cities
and then the journalists on msnbc and
cnn and then
sort of the big tech oligarchs that can
figure out ways to pit us against each
other
that's the woke thing and you know and
then there's like an academic version of
it obviously there's a lot of
brainwashing
at colleges most of us
are the first thing most of us are just
like live and let live
this place is pretty good it ain't
perfect we can acknowledge that we can
always make it better
but i don't want your stuff i'm not
entitled
like most people really understand that
most people are rational actors
rational self-interest but i mean that
really most people are decent i
fundamentally believe that
but i don't believe that the machine is
decent and what the lefties seem to
believe is if we could just give the
machine
enough power if bernie could just have
enough power or now biden
if we if he could just take more from
some people if we could just
fix all these things in the history that
he never fixed i mean biden's been in
politics for 47 years
he did he never mentioned systemic
racism before now
it's his life's cause it's like come on
so you either believe that humans are
imperfect creatures and that we can just
deal with the mess and that you're gonna
figure out your life the best way you
know how and i'm just not entitled
to your stuff and if you make a lot of
money more than me maybe i can
look at that as the star that i want to
get to if that's important to me
or you believe that a bunch of imperfect
creatures can create a perfect system
and that's what these people are doing i
mean this this is marxism they basically
want a whole bunch of flawed people
we're all flawed
to create a system that if you just
behave within that system if you just
act as a cog in that system
you'll get you'll be you'll own nothing
and you'll be happy that's like the meme
out there but going back yeah
those rules don't apply to them no it
never replies of course
i mean look at the leader of black lives
matter who
bought a house in topanga canyon in los
angeles which is
99.7 white now i i don't care about any
of that stuff
she's the one that purports to but she's
bought and bought something like four
million dollars worth of real estate in
the last couple years
it's like this is the greatest grift
going of all time
have they sent any young black people to
colleges have they built any
institutions
no they're just here to tear everything
down that that's the fundamental
difference
i think liberty minded people or
individualist minded people
want to build things and if you want to
build things that's hard you know about
you know it is hard work to build a
company to build institutions
to build places of higher learning
notice they don't do any of that what
they're really good at is
america is horrible we're going to
destroy the whole thing there was
a beautiful moment in the in the
democratic uh
uh debate early on before everybody
dropped out and they all
got behind the guy with dementia i think
we'll get to that a little bit
um but there was a beautiful moment
where mayor pete
turned to bernie and he said bernie you
want to burn it all down i don't
that was actually the one true moment in
the whole thing that's what they're here
to do
we could all do that we could all set
fire to something but to build something
is is way harder
when you think about um kind of this
whole thing
right uh and it is
economic it is political it is uh
cultural philosophy you know uh
philosophical like there's always
different elements to it
is there one point where you say like if
we could fix this one element
the rest of the system would kind of uh
self-correct
is it the media is it the
economist is it uh literally the
politicians
is it the education system or is it no
this is a complex system and like there
is no one place to kind of
solve that's probably right that's
probably it it's a complex system in a
country of 350 million people
that is an idea dennis prager talks
about this a lot that the beauty of
america is that it's this idea
that people can come from all over the
world with whatever their traditions are
their food their
their family structures all of those
things you can come here
and america says hey go for it we're not
going to get in your way go for it we're
going to treat you all equally
that's the thing they're trying to undo
right now but i would say the system
because you got 350 million people with
all sorts of different beliefs and
backgrounds and all that
to me the best system is one that just
gets the freaking hell out of the way
which is exactly what was set up
i guess probably the the most sensible
answer to the question would be that it
would be education
if if young people were actually taught
like good decent principles that we
probably were you grew up in jersey
right
uh north carolina in north carolina okay
wait i thought you were a jersey guy
well entire family is you're you're okay
i stay there okay
right so my dad and mom ran away and uh
right right right
in north carolina all right so but all
right so i grew up in new york and most
of my family lived in jersey
public schools and there were good
decent public schools it doesn't mean
they did everything right but you got
like some sort of
sense of like a robust education and all
that the schools have been so like can
you imagine having
sending your kids to a public school
right now to be taught that
boys have vaginas and girls have penises
and that if they're white they're
automatically racist
and that the history of the country
didn't the country didn't start in 1776
it started in 1619
and that the prime the primacy of
everything of the country was driven by
racism and slavery i mean
you'd be sending you're basically
sending your kids to a brainwashing
institution so i guess
fixing education would be number one i
think that's long gone i think the ship
has freaking sailed
the the teachers unions are so deeply
corrupt they have been infected by the
the woke virus they're gone i think
maybe the other answer would be
yeah if we had a decent media if we had
imagine there was just
10 people in the media like
mainstreamers
so i'm not talking about somebody that
maybe woke up recently like glenn
greenwald i'm talking about
if we could turn on a channel and
reincarnate walter cronkite and maybe he
wasn't that great and we've just sort of
canonized him now but imagine if there
was like a couple people in america that
you really
felt boy you're really getting some
honest true assessment of what's going
on here
that would help a lot because otherwise
the fraying that we have right now is
just
going to keep going but i just don't
know it's it's a good question because
it's like is this thing just too big
probably is like it's too big to fail in
some way but now it's too big to succeed
the woke virus as you described it the
wokeness
um we've talked about in the past i have
example after example
of a virtue signaling element of it
right where people basically are saying
one thing when given the opportunity to
do
something uh with money or time or
whatever
they don't follow through with what you
would they like other people's money
yeah that is one way to put it yeah uh
is this just a natural evolution of a
society
like yeah you kind of ascend to the
global superpower
you won right like you're the top uh
everyone gets fat and happy
complacent yep and then rather than stay
on guard
and uh and be worried about what comes
next you basically just turn
inward and all the fat you know uh rich
people all start screaming at each other
about
oh you know give me your food give me
yours ple you know you almost imagine
like ancient rome
yeah right yeah like the fat guys laying
around like just trying to like yell and
scream at each other and then eventually
like
roam falls yeah that well i'll i
absolutely think that's right
the analogy i was always giving related
to trump was that trump was the guy
guarding the gate at the castle and all
of the elites instead of being like
maybe we should help that guy
they were actually mocking him and
trying to take him out they were
basically like trying to cut his
achilles heel
while the barbarians were at the gate
and in this case the barbarians i mean
the workstars the i
the people that have decided that this
thing
that we are a part of is not good notice
nobody leaves right nobody leaves
america everyone's still if we hope if
we fully opened up
our borders the way they would like we
would be overrun overnight
anyone can leave america where no one's
going the craziest most bananas carl
reiner
uh you know any just pick any of these
lefty hollywood people they never leave
they never leave why because it's pretty
freaking spectacular here
and they would never make the money they
make or live the life they make and it's
geographically great and they know it's
good they're they're making money off
of very confused people um
so i think the basically you had
all of the elites just mocking the guy
who was guarding the gate
and yes it's that we got fat on freedom
we got it's been so good here for so
long the levels of freedom and wealth
that we've done for everybody uh is so
extraordinary
and is is the jealousy the world over uh
that we
turn yeah you're right we turned it on
ourselves we were suddenly like oh
is any of this good and then you know
you couple that with just
with really bad education as we've
talked about before and everything else
and then it's like yeah now the system
is just like
it's just kind of hanging on and
you know to me it's like there we had a
real chance it's very odd for me
i did not support trump until september
of 20
uh was 2019. no 2020 it was the election
so 2020.
and now it's like so you were anti just
i voted for gary johnson in 2016. okay
um you know the libertarian gary johnson
he was not a great candidate
[Music]
aleppo was and and just like he wanted
the baker to bake the gay cake which
made no
sense from a libertarian perspective he
and he was also just
i've hung out with the guy actually and
he's been on my show he's a nice guy
like i'd like to smoke weed with him and
go skiing
that's what he really wants to do but
instead he pretends he's a politician so
i voted for him and then i had three
years of of really like the red pilling
process
and really at the end of it it was like
well then i might have to like
kind of suck it up and be like yeah that
guy who talks funny who's a bit of a
dick
and a troll and yeah maybe he is the
only thing that the system could choke
out
that's what i kind of came to on trump
it was like it wasn't that he was this
great statesman that we all would have
wanted right like i would much prefer
that we have a true statesman like get
me jfk again but
that that doesn't exist a broken system
can only give you broken people in a way
and trump
was just like i'll do it i don't want to
do it but i'll do it but if you
you want to watch something interesting
on youtube go and watch trump interviews
in the 80s with oprah when she's begging
him to run for president and he's on
donahue
he's saying the exact same things now
there's a netflix
netflix special oh is there there's a
netflix uh he's called
the american dream and he's 33 years old
or 32 years old and he's in his office
and a reporter basically is like you
know you're gonna run for president one
day
if you listen to it and you didn't see
him you would have thought he was 75
years old saying the same thing i mean
it's
almost to a t yeah exactly no he was
saying the same stuff
he's not his orange he's not his gruff
his uh
the way he speaks is a little bit
different you know now it's it blew my
mind by the way like
like it was no it was shocking because i
was like oh my god like this
i didn't know that like i'm not old
enough to have understood that like
literally here is a video uh wow
does he say the line in that does he say
the line well i want other people to do
it first
he's always because every time that i
heard him say it in the 80s when i watch
these videos
he always says the same thing which is
well he's like well i wish somebody else
will do it like i hope
i hope i don't want to do it and that to
me is what you'd want out of a president
you'd want somebody that would be like i
really don't want to rule the world but
if everything else is so messed
up then maybe it takes like this crooked
new york city
uh you know builder i mean to be a
builder in new york city
like you're gonna have to do some shady
stuff but maybe that was the only
chance so put trump aside for a second
yeah uh and i want to come back to the
presidential
futures that we have yeah but um my
favorite episode i've ever had on the
podcast
is uh somebody damned me on twitter and
he even said hey man
uh i'm a regular dude you don't know me
no reason why you ever will know me
i like to come on your podcast and talk
about why i like bitcoin
i've probably got that message a hundred
times over two years never even
responded any of them for some reason
just something in me just said
respond responded i said great why don't
you come on the podcast tomorrow
or two days from now we did a remote
interview and
uh afterwards he tells me that he
literally was so nervous that he got his
wife to take their kids and their dog
and like get the hell out of the house
and he likes put this whole thing set up
and he had lamps and like
he was into it right it's my favorite
interview because
he said one sentence to me that is like
seared in my brain
he said look man he's a he did a tile
and flooring in canada
i don't want to rule the world i just
want to create a better life for my
family that's it
and i just always think like that is
majority of the population yeah
there are psychos who want to rule the
world but majority of people do not give
a [ __ ] about
other people or other things or whatever
they're just saying if i can create a
better life for my family be happy
and spend time with people i love great
life that's it
that's how you find purpose and meaning
and everything else right
like think about it right now i'm i
don't know i
met them on the street but like i don't
know what my neighbor thinks about
anything
basically he could be a communist do you
think that you think
they probably know what i think which i
can always tell when they know because
then i people well before kobe people
used to cross the street now i know why
they're across the street
but but usually when people see me that
almost oh we were just at west elm
before we walked in here a guy came
right up to me like
it's funny because on on twitter people
are horrible because anonymity and all
that
people in real life no one has ever come
up to me and said anything negative
i'll get i'll get some mean looks but no
one has ever and i hope you know knock
on wood that continues but
don't worry i got a couple brothers we
can change that
that's got the studio on the street over
here um
but but in essence um i don't know what
my neighbor does
what they believe in any of that stuff
and i don't care
as long as the toxic goo of whatever
they're doing doesn't leak into my
property
as long as they're not doing anything to
affect my life that's the beauty of
america
do whatever you want so you don't hurt
anybody yeah i mean that in essence
that's the most libertarian approach to
everything or or like in some way it's
a very like and cap approach that
there's just no interference in anything
i'm not fully there on all that i think
we need
some basic guard rails you know like
it's just you need some reality
um but that's that's it so when you
again when you ask about that center
thing and like what most
we are but but good people are afraid to
say that think how many people you
probably know in your own life
who are just afraid to say that because
the woke have tricked them into thinking
if you don't say your woke or post a
black
picture on instagram or a virtue signal
that you were at some rally
even though you don't know why they're
there i love those videos where they
send interviewers in and they're like
who died and why are you here and
they're like what what you know like all
of that nonsense
but yes most people are live and let
live i firmly firmly believe that
when i have dinner in private with
people i always like to ask
one of two questions uh one we're not
going to talk about because we don't
have time
but the second one i want to talk to you
about first question i always ask is
what's the one thing you believe
that you would feel is politically
incorrect to say in public
you get a whole plethora of answers from
climate change stuff
to political stuff to literally you know
uh sexual preference i mean all kinds of
crazy stuff right
so like that's just a great thing
because like you really understand who
somebody is and
how they think whatever the second
question i like to ask because it's just
pure
freaking entertainment and my wife
always just rolls her eyes i say
who's the craziest most unassuming
future president that you could see like
who's the person that you think could be
president
yeah that other people will be like
that's nuts and i've always said two
people and then i want to hear your
answer yeah
the first is the rock yeah i genuinely
believe yeah the rock is gonna be the
president united states
he's charismatic he's intelligent he's
funny
there's a bunch of studies that show the
most physically
kind of dominant person if you put them
up on stage like people just feel like
oh that's supposed to be the leader
uh and i used to joke that you know
trump's like a big guy 6-4
or whatever standing next to dwayne
johnson and he said something stupid
dwayne johnson's like shut your candy
ass up everyone would laugh and like
you could just very quickly see like he
could navigate his way to become the
president of popularity contest
the second person which now people are
like all right this guy's crazy
kim kardashian super recognizable
many people think she's attractive she
has a
very very high degree of expertise
in transitioning from
let's call it a sex tape stage to
reality star
to now criminal justice reform and
lawyer to
maybe governor to president like you
could see a path where somebody is
actually very intelligent you listen
like the david letterman uh interview
she just on netflix
you listen you're like that's not what
the media has portrayed her as
like she's actually very very
intelligent uh and then you add in all
these other things around fame and
popularity and and culture et cetera
and you start to realize like is this
gonna be a popularity contest yeah
like is it literally just gonna come
down to like who runs the high school
like uh student body president campaign
and hands out lollipops
right like they'll be handing out ubi is
what they'll be handing out it's not
gonna be like is that is that like
how we determine president moving
forward just like who's the most popular
who's the biggest social media following
they win
probably yes right like that's probable
but
that's the best argument for limited
government that there possibly is that
that whatever happens so whether it's
the rock
or kim kardashian or who is yours or or
the ghost of gary coleman whatever it is
is like whatever it is that it won't
affect you that much so who
that that's a good question i mean like
who's the the person that is the most
out of left field
but you still believe they can become
president well this isn't out of left
field at all but i honestly believe that
candace owens could become president
really yeah yeah okay explain because
that i think that will surprise a lot of
people well
first off she's been you know she was a
lefty
she then you know she went all the way
from left to trump support as i said she
snorted that thing
and then bam she was off the red pill
the red pill
yeah and she she's absolutely clear
about her opinions she's completely
fearless she has fought the machine
she never lets the machine beat her she
fights and fights and fights
it's extraordinary i also know her very
well she this is a great human being
like
she really is a great human being her
tactics are a little different than mine
you know what i mean we always talk
about that like
sometimes i don't even do it as much
anymore but i used to try to win more
with candy than always be on the attack
i'm i'm on the
attack more now than i used to be
because i think there's just not a lot
of
ways to get these people related to
decency and logic and all that kind of
stuff
i think she's just prepared and and
but i guess that's not out of left field
you want you want to add a left field
um like somebody who's not involved in
politics maybe like a matthew
mcconaughey
yeah i know like he's kind of waking up
now he did a couple shows with jordan
peterson
he understands like purpose he's really
into purpose
hums a little bit pounds his chest yeah
there's and everyone's like all right
he whispers whatever he did in
interstellar i just watched that again
the other day like
like something like you know but again
that's just the celebrity thing
yeah but but there's substance there oh
yeah no no there's
absolutely substance there but but it's
unfortunate because if you go back i
mean literally if you say
this is like the nerdiest thing i could
possibly tell you but if you looked at
the like
books and uh literature that i have in
my bathroom like when i'm reading on the
toilet
i have like tons of like founding
documents from the united states and
what
these people what jefferson was writing
to atoms and all these things you read
these things like literally spend
two minutes glancing through one of
these things you will think my god these
people were so much better than us
they were so for as much as i like trump
as i said he was just necessary at that
time
he has nothing on these guys like their
understanding about what the world
was what freedom was what believing in
things outside of yourself bigger than
you
allowing people to do what they want
next door to you like
so it's like we need those people back
but our system
and twitter and algorithms and gotcha
and a dishonest media
none of that adds up to a good decent
learned man becoming president of the
united states
i always think about and um it's a sad
thought uh but i talk to friends about
all time
i do not have any of my smartest friends
who want to go to be a teacher
or a politician not one of my smartest
friends even remotely has considered it
yeah that tells you all you need to know
and i'm like man what are you guys going
to do
technology or wall street well that's
kind of beautiful actually so let's take
the good version okay so the good
version of it is that
the good people that you know like the
most thoughtful interesting probably
creative they're gonna do stuff right
like instead of teaching about it and
you know i'm not fully saying this but
you know the old adage is those who
can't do teach
so the people that you're talking about
they're gonna go build these things
that's what's so cool about miami right
now it's like
literally i got off the plane i could
like feel it it felt real to me i was
like whoa
there's something going on here it's
happening here you know that's exciting
and awesome
and it also breeds more of it you know
what i mean there's a little bravery
there
and then you see all of this new stuff
happening and then other people are like
wait there's something new there i want
to go some fine
it feels like the new land bingo it's
the wild west that's what i say it's
like they're they're actually finding
what you guys are doing here and what i
now think we're doing by bringing locals
here is
we are now finding the undiscovered
country and let's
let's build it together it's it's
awesome and by together i mean we're
going to build it individually and then
see how that thing kind of kind of gets
bundled but
so that's the good version of it that
those people probably did great things
the bad version is yes then you will
only get these broken
corrupt bankrupt morally or
or financially so they're doing it for
money you know how many politicians go
in
with very average lifestyles and go out
with mega millions
way too many of them we just won't get
look i've had a ton of people
begged me to run for governor of
california because i've been so
outspoken about the recall
that's a baby that looks like a maybe i
wouldn't say
zero but the state is so freaking
corrupt
that the idea that you could do anything
is how would you do it well how would i
do it
all right so i've asked mark cuban
before if you ever ran for president how
would he do it yeah and he had a
fascinating answer
uh and to his credit uh it was a
thoughtful answer given that he probably
hadn't spent that much time thinking
about it but like if you
sat down right now you said okay i have
to run for governor like how do you win
well i would
i mean if that i've thought about enough
okay which would be that i would
take zero dollars other than fundraising
for whatever
the absolute minimum would be to be on
all the ballots so just i just want to
be on all the balls
i i would do no mainstream press period
i will not go on msnbc i will not go on
cnn
i can't say i wouldn't go on fox
actually because they've actually been
very good to me they let me go on and
say whatever i want even when it's
counter
to the say conservative or republican
narrative
um but i would not play with those
children that have just
completely wrecked media i have a show i
have a voice i would i would talk to
youtubers i would go on podcasts
and i would say here's what i want to do
to fix california we're going to lower
taxes for everybody 25
tomorrow we're cutting the budget by 40
tomorrow
sorry sorry like these things don't work
you know what's happening in california
right now because
we have the recall so newsom who is an
evil disney cartoon character villain
this is a horrible human being
uh he's suddenly getting rid of the
homeless people they're suddenly
disappearing i don't know what he's
doing to them
but where i live under the underpass has
been a freaking
massive like you almost have to be like
actually
you have to admire the ingenuity of
these people i'm like you guys are
building like three level
tents like this is impressive but it's
been there for like a year
last week suddenly gone and i'm noticing
now around parts of la
it's starting to disappear because he
knows he has about a three-month window
before the
recall election to fully clean the place
up so everyone forgets
so he he's just truly evil but i would
say why the reason i don't want to do it
is because of what you just laid out i
want to build awesome things
i love talking about the ideas that
we're talking about here
i love the fact that i'm in the tech
world now which i never
never expected this and now i spend
probably
probably more than half my day doing
locals related things and talking to
people
about all the solutions whether they're
technological or philosophical
or legal or whatever it might be and i
love that so i feel like i'm a
productive member of society why would i
be governor
like they're going to call me at 3am and
be like governor rubin there was a
earthquake in santa barbara and it's
like all right you know call me in the
morning like what do you want me to do
so that would be a horrible governor
well i feel like somebody should do
something about that but but that also
is part of it if you're really a
thriving person
in this world right like i consider
myself a thriving person not a perfect
person but i consider myself a thriving
person
why would you want to be in government
why would i want to be in the thing
that's there to control people which by
the way
that's why you get horrible people in
government they can't really
so andrew yang i think is a really
interesting one because he's sort of
loved in our circles
and i always think it's really bizarre
it's like why aren't you doing
more than why aren't you building great
tech and great things why do you keep
wanting to go into government
it doesn't really make sense to me like
you know you failed presidential bid
then you went to georgia because you
wanted to help the democrats win which i
guess did happen or
it did happen now you're running for
mayor it doesn't look like that's gonna
happen i guess after this he's gonna run
again it's like
you seem like the title all the tech
people seem to like you or
yeah i don't really like him either i
can sort of read your i uh
i just think i think it's all hype i
think it's all hype go ahead i have a
story
he also threw me under the bus in the
new york times okay so you don't like
him
well because the questioner uh asked
said why do you go
on these right-wing shows like like the
dave rubin show which isn't even a show
that's not the name of my show where he
ra the quote was where he
regularly hosts white supremacists and
not only did yang not push back on that
um but he basically was like well if the
lefties would be nicer i wouldn't have
to do shows like that
and i was like what's your policy on
cursing you do i was basically like [ __ ]
you man like that's
that's such why people think you're just
a cardboard nothing
because like you beg not no he can't say
he begged me to do my show he wanted to
do my show
i was thrilled to have him i treated him
with the same respect i treat everybody
else
and now a new york times person
basically calls me a white supremacist
and you kind of
you know you don't say no it's just
gross all right so here's my uh yeah
isn't it funny though i could read it
from you just by like yeah your eyebrow
basically was like well
here here's why um i don't know him yeah
so i have to
carry out that i've never had a
one-on-one conversation with yeah so
like in all these situations i'm always
like the best
the best thing ever would be that you
could sit down with each candidate have
a
hour-long meal with them and then walk
away all right this one but like you
know tulsi gabbard i did that with her
on the show and i freaking loved her and
we become good friends and she's an
honest good woman
before yang said he was running for
president
i happened to go to a conference that he
spoke at
i was very off put to the point of like
i was like man that guy
doesn't make sense and at the conference
i think it was at the conference or
maybe right after the conference he
announced he's running for president and
i literally remember being like
what like like that can't be real what
was it that he was saying
that that it wasn't even like a specific
thought like a specific idea of like hey
i'm going to do this or i'm going to do
this or whatever
it was just this idea of like man that
is commentary
on somebody who is talking about a topic
that hasn't done the topic i totally
agree and it was just a
very very weird feeling you just you can
tell it's like when you listen to a
professor
talk about like uh economic policy and
you're like
man you have never wagered money in the
market cause let me tell you
anyone you would be broke yeah like you
would be bankrupt already yeah
yeah and uh and for whatever reason i
don't know why
no i actually think that he's like seems
like a really personal people people
love him like all this
and like i feel bad even saying any of
this but for whatever reason that was my
experience i could be a hundred percent
off i'm wrong all the time about people
but like in that one moment
i remember thinking to myself like
there's zero shot and then when i like
saw you know six months twelve months
later whatever it was and like how far
he
or maybe was like two years before the
actual election this had happened yeah
i remember being like whoa he got really
far
and along the way like i think the
machine worked against them and like the
whole yang blackout
like on all the complaints as to why
like he probably didn't do as well as he
could have done but then he needed to
fight it
you know what i mean like if he'd never
talked about it yeah yeah so like but
but just like that i think was the
closest
that i got to talking to one of the
candidates
yeah and i remember being like wow if
like you got that far
even though the machine was working
against you like huh okay your data
point right
but so it's interesting because what
you're saying actually totally like
puzzle pieces with what i said i mean
it's it's sort of the same thing like
it was sort of with him it was just like
there's no there there and i actually
it's interesting you say because i
really don't i go out of my way on my
show not to talk
about people other than politicians or
media members
i don't find like the average pundit or
just like guy on the street to like be
railing on but yes i'll make fun of aoc
and i'll make fun of biden and whatever
but it's interesting because yeah it's
like
i saw all my kind of tech friends and my
media people
everyone loved him and i was like i'm
always careful with this though
because we see it because it was their
way of just saying i'm not voting for
trump
that's what it was it was basically all
the all the decent remaining liberals
like the non-woke liberals
who all knew that trump wasn't as bad
and foresee i know
freaking a lot of them voted for trump
privately a lot of them i'm talking
public people
like a lot of them did and i just didn't
want to do that i didn't feel that i
could lie to my audience in that way
um but i think they saw yang as like all
right he's not
an insane democrat like so
i'll just pretend i'm doing that and
then when yang went out
then they all just sort of backed biden
and whatever
yeah what's up guys bang bang i hope
you're enjoying this conversation
but before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
block five block five's got four
different financial products for crypto
investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use our cryptocurrency exchange
and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
then when you swipe
you get bitcoin back rather than
cashback or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user i think you will be too
when you go to blockfy.com pomp
again blockfy.com go check it out and
let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it uh
let's talk about the media
yeah which uh you have no opinions about
um it feels like uh i'm going to
tell you the framework that i've used in
the past i usually talk about the
financial media yeah that's where i
spend most of my time
uh but i'm interested if this is how the
political media works as well so
you're good on those shows by the way i
i've seen you on a bunch of those shows
you know why
i grew up with four brothers and we just
talked [ __ ] all the time like
that's like that's it that really is it
i can see it when you have like a good
line ready to drop and you know you have
a good line
yeah it's like okay so you're gonna
break three or four people or you're
gonna like throw out the top and we're
all gonna argue
yeah okay that's basically what i did up
my entire life growing up yeah and my
brothers by the way they're like
watching like oh my god you know
like this is a complete joke that this
is like literally on television
people are going to watch this um but
the the framework that i use
is uh so there's journalists people who
do real journalism
uh unequivocally you put them in that
category they
write unbiasedly as best as a human can
do
they talk to sources they uh actively
pursue the truth
and they're doing journalism yeah you
can say that maybe they're not
perfect or whatever but like they're
doing journalism they're journalists and
that's what they're trying to do
not many of those not many of them but
that's what they're that that's the
bucket you put them yeah
then there is uh on the other extreme i
call market participants
so in finance these are people who are
investors who are founders or whoever
uh they are actively participating in
the market and they uh everything from
blogs to podcasts to like these other
things they're
very clearly not journalists uh and they
say look the reason why i'm talking
about this is because i spend all day
doing this i
put my time and effort or i put capital
at risk and
i win or lose and there's skin in the
game for what i'm doing
and then there's the middle group in the
middle group i call the bloggers
masquerading as journalists
they are highly biased yeah they don't
even hide it
like if you go to some of these websites
it's opinion pieces that are literally
written as articles yeah like they're
like they're like where's the opinion
component of this
tried the new york times and so this is
what i wanted this is what i want to
hear
and then the other piece that's
fascinating to me about this
is when you look at the the content
itself so there's the process of which
the content gets written so if i just
sit down every morning and i just write
my personal opinion about stuff in my
analysis
i'm not a journalist right right like i
am a talking ad i'm an opinion writer
by the way that's fine but the problem
with that
is if you are wrong over and over and
over and over again there's no
punishment because you don't get fired
and you didn't lose any money
so like you basically just can keep
[ __ ] over and over and over but
the content is literally just
a regurgitation of the state talking
points
it is like i mean if you go back and you
read like throughout the entire pandemic
it was like
we should give everyone money all of the
wall street firms are bad people we
shouldn't help them but we should help
all the poor people
and uh the debt won't matter there will
be no inflation and like just go
go go go help the people i can't believe
you're helping the people
and now it's like well time out everyone
who has any money and any
intelligence was like you can't bring
trillions of dollars and not get
inflation
and now they're like oh it's transitory
or or even worse they just gaslight and
they're like
we knew it was gonna be transitory of
you're like
what planet are we living on but by the
way they do that with everything so i
love the fact that you're talking about
her from the financial world which is
not totally my world but the thing that
you see
is the same thing that i see coming from
where the political campaign and it's
the same thing that i think people see
from the
say scientific world or from any
discipline so like it's like fouchy is
now kind of like oh we always sort of
were saying that maybe it was a lab leak
i'm not telling you it's a lab leak
i'm saying that we should at least be
allowed to talk about it and suddenly
you know it's like jon stewart now
mentioned it on colbert the other night
so now all the good liberals who were
trying to get everybody banned from
twitter who
when trump said this a year ago you know
he's a racist and he's
trying to get chinese people killed or
whatever it's like well now
the liberal leader said it so now
they're all allowed to say it so jon
stewart said it
on the show as like john colbert he
basically was like yeah it could be a
lab league
and he and by the way him doing that on
colbert that's the system
if you like when we talk about like
whatever the system is i don't know how
to exactly
my favorite question was like who runs
the system right so nobody knows no but
nobody knows but but when you think
about what
is the system the system is jon stewart
who's basically been mia for years
there's been a lot of things to talk to
he was in his ass
joe rogan yeah right exactly literally
um
but the system having john trotting out
jon stewart the sort of
good guy media liberal you know more
young people got their news from the
daily show than anywhere else which was
just a meme of nonsense
but like the media loves this guy him
going on colbert
to say the lab league hypothesis is
possible it's at least worthy of being
talked about
that's the system a year before somebody
got banned from the
zero hedge got banned from twitter hedge
got banned from twitter trump literally
said it and they called him a racist and
said he was insane
um but that's the system so i don't know
who's running that so who's running that
i don't know the agents that put the
thing like it's not the agent so it's
like i don't know we can keep going up
to something
crazy is it fair to say and this is
really it's the airlock that's my point
it's the airlock yeah is it fair to say
though that you're separating out
jon stewart from again the idea that
a year ago you could you could not say
things now you can say things
and because they're different groups
saying those things and it's a year
apart also we treat it completely
different
yeah because because in essence what
happens there is an
apparent you know it seems like in the
last say month
the lab leak hypothesis was gaining so
much traction online
that the system then has to be like okay
we have to we can't ignore this anymore
i think we kicked off youtube now if
we're talking about lab leaks or no i
think no now we're okay
not only now we're okay but facebook
will now allow you to do it they were
kicking a year ago there was no
i literally would tell guests like
timeout we can't talk about this stuff
you know on my show this is slight
sidebar but on my show for the first
time
ever we had to edit for content i've
interviewed i don't know thousands of
people
never once edited for content well one
time because i guess come in so drunk
and stoned that
we had to get rid of about half the
interview because i thought it was just
going to ruin their career
but a few weeks ago i had david horowitz
on he is uh he was the original sort of
why i left the left guy that's sort of
what i thought of us now
this is a guy he's 83 years old oh my
son is uh
is ben horowitz oh okay sorry yeah yeah
uh the audience would have been
the audience but his dad his dad was the
why i left the left guy was a was a
communist as a kid
anyway when reagan was being re-elected
and his parents were marxist
when reagan was being re-elected he was
a lefty but decided that he wanted to
support reagan
and then basically his whole life since
then has been the left trying to destroy
him he's
really really fascinating guy anyway ben
horowitz by the way
is absolutely fascinating because uh
he sits at the intersection
of so many different religion race
technology
industry now his dad politic like yeah
fascinating every time i learn more
about him he's just like
i've actually only talked to him once
he's obviously a fascinating guy but
his dad in essence on my show a few
weeks ago said he said his own
personal opinion about the results of
the election
and i let people say what they want on
my show and we had to
we blurred it where we bleeped it and we
put the full thing on locals but i knew
my youtube channel could have been taken
out just like that really
that's you know we can get into tech and
center censorship and all that but in
essence what i think happened with jon
stewart was
the thing was bubbling up so much online
and by the way this is exactly what's
going to happen with biden and dementia
because now it's everyone's talking
about it except mainstream media and
they can't hide it much longer
so then what happens is the system has
to basically be like all right
we have to normalize this now we we
can't hide it anymore too many people
know
so then oh why don't we bring out jon
stewart the trusted name in america who
hasn't had an opinion on anything in all
in
four years since leaving the show let's
bring him out he'll say it
then all the conspiracy theorists and
the right-wing crazy people
they were actually all crediting john
they were like oh that's so nice to hear
now the problem is that john won't make
the full
like the full like get there you've got
to leave the democratic party
you know the joke now right what
conspiracy theorists are just like
people who are
early yeah exactly take take all of the
people that are like the actual hardcore
conspiracy not the people who like are
on twitter saying stupid stuff yeah
right like i'm talking about like people
who legitimately you would put in the
category of conspiracy theorists
i'll go out on a limb and i will say uh
although most of us
wish it wasn't true they're more right
than we originally gave them all credit
for of course is
scary it because it goes to everything
we're talking about here that the media
cannot be trusted anymore that the
institutions can't be trusted
that big tech is doing big tech is
manipulating us in ways we cannot
imagine it's not just the ways
you and i are fairly versed in tech it's
like it's not just the ways that they
can manipulate us through searches and
de-boosting and uh shadow banning
i'm worried about the things we can't
even think of that they can do to us you
know what i mean
the way that that that if you have one
political opinion the way that they
could just force feed you other
videos to just change your opinion on
anything like we're basically all in
this mass
we're in this mass dystopian experiment
right now
but long story short i think they they
basically tried to jon stewart out there
because it was like we can't hide this
anymore let's legitimize it now because
now there must be something to it
and this is exactly what's going to
happen with mine did you see um
when all this was happening uh there was
a pseudo-anonymous
uh report on kovid that got put out
you see this so i'm not sure i'm not
gonna remember all the details
so already i'm wrong right but but uh
conspiracy theories basically
a group of people i don't think it was
one person but i don't think it was
necessarily a hundred people right but a
group of people got together
they did not put their names on it
there's a pseudonymous thing
and it wasn't a google document but it
was like some sort of collaborative
software that they used
they basically wrote a report and this
was widely shared in the tech community
specifically
uh a lot of folks who spent their time
as investors or founders
like in the early part they were trying
to figure out data and i joked like
over the last year i didn't realize how
many uh uh virologists how many
uh epidemiologists how many uh uh
economists you know all you know uh
political uh voter legal experts i had
in my feed right
like all sudden people started popping
up yeah
but this report literally was probably
one of the best things i read
and it was all written in
uh using pseudonymous names and what
fascinated me was
they did it to protect themselves but it
was very obvious these were intelligent
people
i'm sure it wasn't 100 right i'm sure
there was errors whatever but given the
information they had at the time
they wrote a very compelling piece and
they touched on everything from like
here's how big it could get like all the
things you would want to read and like
understand it right
and i start to think more and more and
more you've mentioned a couple times
like the machine working against people
people who are on the left want to go
more to the right people on the right
uh you know the everyday person or or
elites or whatever
and it just feels like bolaji
srinivasan's whole like
pseudonymous economy i've been thinking
about this world
that's where we're headed because people
are literally just gonna be so fearful
of like anything i say with my name on
it
is literally going to be used against me
later so the irony is i did a video a
year ago when my book came out we
released it that day uh for prageru
called the bravery deficit and that's
what we have in the country we just have
a bravery deficit
the way is that a bravery deficit in
essence is that not enough people are
just
willing to say what they think that's
the way we defeat this thing if you
wanted wokeness to be blown out of the
water tomorrow
like it would literally just all it
would take would be enough people just
lying in the sand this is this is who i
am this is i'm gonna fight for the
things i believe in by the way we're
starting to see a little bit of it more
you know you keep seeing these videos
of like these angry moms going to school
board meetings and yelling you're
telling my five-year-old
boy that he's a girl and that he's
racist like no more of this [ __ ]
so more and more people are getting
brave because we're seeing that the
machine
the machine can't destroy all of us it
preys on the fact
that the fear keeps us all sort of just
docile in essence um but i think that
so we have to just get oh if we can get
over the fear thing
we will defeat that and then wait what
was the question exactly well
just as the pseudo-anonymous economy
like grows
yeah it's going to be out of that fear
of people putting their name on this
right so look
there's great arguments to be made both
ways here i completely get
why people are anonymous online you
don't want they don't go for your job
they're going to go for your family
we've allowed for political violence now
in the streets of america like i
fully get it on the other hand the fact
that so many people
are on anonymous online constantly
encourages the worst behavior possible
so if i was to ever i actually don't
look at my twitter mentions anymore i
look at the verified ones but i don't
look at the
the just regular ones and that kind of
sucks because it used to be fun but then
i think you have a version of this too
when you get to a certain
amount of followers the bots and the
trolls and just the house
you should respond to every single
person oh god not anymore
yeah not anymore not anymore you want to
stay sane
but but what happens is if you on the
rare occasion that i do actually can
click there's a way you can click
through
even if you're hiding them and see them
what i notice is virtually
everyone that says the horrible [ __ ]
that they're saying to me all day long
that i don't see
they're all anonymous so you've
incentivized horrible behavior and then
you have
so i always think it's hilarious when i
see people in our world that are like
really well-known phds and doctors and
lawyers and
you know tech leaders and they're
arguing with anonymous people all day
long
it's like if you want to spend time
arguing online then at least
argue with non-anonymous people so that
there's some some level
of say you know you look them in the eye
when you're right like a little bit
right a little bit
but on the other hand i get that's not
me going after
the the people that for legitimate
reasons that are just
decent americans or forget americans
that are just decent human beings
that feel they need that so we are going
to have to figure out this
pseudo-anonymous
like are we all did you ever see uh
scanner darkly
yeah it's a philip k dick story it was a
movie with keanu reeves and
it's like an animated movie with keanu
reeves and a couple other people where
basically we're all walking around with
these masks on all the time
and then we don't know who's who at any
given time and we can all be anybody and
we're all nobody
it's a lot of that kind of stuff and
there's it's a really great movie
actually
um but yes we're that's also what the
next part of the internet's gonna have
to figure out
because there's too many burner accounts
there's too many ways to do horrible
things too many ways
to coordinate assaults on websites and
destroy book reviews and
just drive people freaking crazy you
know what i mean if the people that hate
bitcoin
just want to say we're going to freaking
attack pomp maybe they're doing this all
the time they probably are
where every time he tweets we just have
it set in some program and then we have
a bunch of
losers that we're paying a dollar or
whatever and we're just going to blow up
his feed
every freaking day until we just break
this guy because they do it they do it
all the time i mean not just don't read
it
no no but you've gotten to the point
where you're like all right it's not
going to affect me i know what i'm doing
but you also have to have very thick
skin you got it skin and also like
did any of this make us more social you
know it's called social media
it actually made us far more anti-social
and and hateful and distrustful
that's why i'm so proud of what we did
with locals because i open my locals
account
it's freaking love in there it is it is
love and good and decent and i think
it's the promise
of what social media was supposed to be
i'm not telling you it's all perfect
and again i don't believe in perfect
systems but like something
that is happening in the way we are all
communicating on twitter and facebook
and youtube is just wrong and by the way
that's why i never call for
regulating them because the second you
freaking regulate these things
you solidify their existence in the
system forever well and the regulation
makes it worse like that's what that's
right
it'll crush competition yeah i don't
think um i don't think people understand
that and uh
there's someone close to me who always
says uh the the people who do the
canceling
will stop when they get canceled yeah
right like it's like
it's all fun and games until somebody
turns it on you well that's what you see
that's always the best when you see
these lefties who have
i don't i don't want to make everything
about politics but when you see these
people
that have spent their lives trying to
destroy everybody who they disagree with
by calling them bigots and racists and
everything that make them make it so
that they can't get jobs and we're going
to ruin your public
you know personal your public life and
everything else and then it suddenly
turns on them and it's like and then
sometimes i'm like ah maybe
this one does seem unjust maybe i should
defend them and i'm like
you know we all only have like a certain
a certain amount of ammo
there's all these problems uh you went
independent when
the idea of well it was it was a couple
steps to go independent so i left a few
networks i originally left the young
turks and then i was on aura tv which
was a digital network
then i left there and i was on patreon
and i was kind of the first of the
politics guys to be on patreon it was
mostly gamers
and anime people and i i the reason i
wanted to leave aura tv was a digital
network founded by
my friend and mentor larry king the
reason i wanted to leave
was because our show was blowing up and
in essence i think you'll really like
this story actually because
we we were but there's like larry king
with larry king live larry king larry
we were becoming bigger than the network
so we were crushing it and what was
happening was they were taking resources
from our show
in essence to support things that
weren't working and they were constantly
asking us to hit bigger and bigger
metrics and i was like
this doesn't make sense like we're
crushing it we're doing
really good stuff but they're basically
taking from us and
and i mean you get the social as part of
this so i was like i was like let's just
go
let's try it let's try to do this on our
own see if we can do it build a studio
do the whole thing
took my producer and my director all
quit our jobs salaries
health care the whole thing we launched
on patreon and it was a monday morning
this is this is now around 2016 or so
okay so only five years yeah and this
was just the first step in true
independence
and i said to my guys it was sunday
night at like 11 30 we're about to go to
bed just launch it first thing in the
morning i said i may have completely
[ __ ] up our lives
like i may have like we're screwed if
this doesn't work within about 10
minutes
the next morning once we launched we
were at about 30 grand a month and i was
like we're gonna be okay
and then that really that then and you
were pumping it through social media in
terms of like promoting it
pushed it everywhere i could and people
were people were excited that somebody
was going independent
standing up for what they believe in all
of that kind of stuff
then from there eventually built my own
studio so that was the next part of
being independent i wasn't renting
studio space anymore what you guys have
done here you own this nobody you know
maybe somebody's gonna
you know chop the wire to shut off the
lights but otherwise you know as long as
you pay your bills you're good to go
so that was the next part and then
really what what fully did it was
uh december of 2018 i was uh it was
just about wrapping up you know i toured
with jordan peterson for a year and a
half which was
unfreaking believable i look back on it
like it was a dream we did about 120
shows in 20 countries
in a year in essence and you guys were
just talking at the shows so
i did warm up i would do about 15
minutes a crowd warm-up just get
everybody laughing and having a good
time
um then he would give a i mean this guy
is truly incredible like when people
think that this guy is incredible
he would give an hour and a half lecture
a different hour and a half lecture
every night i never heard the guy give
the same speech twice
sometimes wow sometimes he'd be you know
his 12 rules for life was the book so
sometimes he would go through all 12
rules sometimes he would do one rule
sometimes he would do no rules if he was
just angry at the new york times he
would do an hour and a half on that
like literally sometimes he would be
like you know i bumped into somebody
before the show who told me
uh that they're struggling with drug
addiction and then he talked about like
it was
it was truly and the coolest part of it
was that
i would see him push his intellectual
limits
every night and then he would stop like
he would literally be like
he would be talking about something and
then he'd be like you know that's all i
can say about that tonight i'm gonna
think about it a little bit more and
then the next
day he'd start the show by saying you
know last night i was talking about this
and i thought about it today
so i was basically watching a choose
your own adventure i was watching a book
being written throughout the whole thing
anyway uh we're on tour december 2018
and i was on patreon that's where i was
making like i don't know probably 80 or
90
of my company's rev and there was a guy
by the name of carl benjamin sargon of
akata on youtube he was like an old
school british
liberal decent guy he went on another
channel so now not his patreon channel
not his youtube channel that was
being funded on patreon he went on
somebody else's channel and he said the
n-word
now he did not say it to be racist he
was mocking the people who used that
word patreon immediately deleted his
account
this is where he was making most of his
money running a business now they
offered no
chance of respite there was no way he
could talk to them
and to me that was such an like
extraordinary escalation because
it's one thing for a tech company to
police what you're doing on the
with what you do on their site but if
they're basically watching you
watching what you say on other sites now
we that's like
can we go after you for whatever you do
in your personal life so jordan and i
discussed it
and we had both had we were both
friendly-ish at least with uh with carl
carl uh sargon picad and we both said
okay it's time to leave patreon
and this was a big deal when you guys
left right oh it was i think it was
front page new york times actually yeah
for some reason we didn't know each
other at the time but i i feel like i
remember
it was like a one-two punch almost yeah
and like it'd be
like okay like that's an interesting
data point yeah and then sam harris left
the next day and he was making a ton on
there and then
and then a few other people left but
that is where they where'd they all go
like where'd you go
so what happened so basically so a soft
right over there is my brother-in-law
and he's a tech guy
and i called him and i said listen i
want to leave patreon i need you to put
down what you're doing and build me a
subscription model because that's the
first piece
the first piece is i need to be
financially free and just replicate
like the bare bones patreon stuff then i
contacted
um patrick hollison at stripe we'd
become friendly a little bit and i said
what is
the best example of a subscription page
that we can basically replicate and
build for me not
not locals as a bigger idea just solve
this problem for me
he told us one assaf built it and then
from basically just middle of december
to january you like how a tech company
gets built
well i i just like the fact that you're
like what's the best one right
here what's the person who probably
knows what the best one is no that was
it i was like i don't know patrick this
is what you do and he said this is the
one and
i said that's the one we're going to
build and this tuesop's credit we built
it
and basically i used about three weeks
the end of december into january to tell
all of my people that i am deleting
my patreon on january 15th and i am
launching reubenreport.com which
ultimately became the first test model
for locals
and by doing it on that day and i did it
on a live stream i actually deleted it
live stream and i doxed myself like a
[ __ ] because
i didn't realize that when i pressed the
lead on the patreon thing my my personal
email was gonna pop up
so i literally doxed myself and i was
drunk because i was doing shots of
patron
in honor of leaving patreon so i'm doing
it for so for every thousand dollars i
think that we made
i was gonna do a shot so i literally did
like eight shots of tequila i doxed
myself
i mean it was it was quite a day uh so
there's some less did you know that
did you know that you doxed yourself i
mean you did it
i knew immediately and these people
these sick twisted freaks online i have
been signed up for every porn site you
can imagine people literally paying for
porn for me i mean
these people anyway uh the next day
though
that like that's commitment like when
you literally are like oh i found
someone that i don't like's email
address i'm now going to
it's not that they just signed me up for
free sites people literally i was
getting things like here's your password
thank you still use that email it's long
gone it's long gone but but you know
it's hard to get rid of an email address
so like
push you know whatever anyway this is
the cool part and this is what
really was the the genesis of locals
january 15th closed down patreon
the next morning i woke up and our rev
jumped by about 30 35 percent
from what you would not so you actually
were making more on day one
yeah more on day one and i wasn't doing
rewards so you know patreon is like
tiered words you send them a t-shirt or
you sign things or you do zoom calls
with people
we decided to get rid of all of that if
you want to support
me being independent talking about the
things you care about giving me a chance
to
get more interviews out there expand
these ideas join us we're not doing
rewards anymore so i took away
rewards but it's the bravery thing
people want to support people that they
think are fighting for the things
in their world that they care about it's
why people love you over bitcoin you
they believe
in bitcoin and then here you are
freaking screaming about this thing
even in the last couple weeks where it's
been very messy your guys love you even
more because it's become because it now
has more of a cost
for you right it's not at its peak right
now and all that stuff
so we jump by about 35 and then i said
to us off now we got something here
because now well what else would i need
to be free
i can't just be reliant youtube could
shut me down tomorrow right twitter
could shut me down so let's
replicate these things so we said all
right we gotta build
our own video player we gotta build
audio we gotta build a community
a news feed that's unmanipulated by an
algorithm and by the way having a
paywall there's no trolls there's no
bots it's all good behavior in there
and if you want to pay me to troll me
well now i can either profit off you
or i boot you out of my locals community
but you could still be in anyone else's
locals community which is very different
because
on twitter if you're booted you're
de-platformed all together
so i think by building something that
was right for me as a creator we have
built something that i think solves
probably 95
of the problems for 95 percent of the
people it doesn't solve alex jones's
problems and i don't know that i want to
be in that
business but and now we have awesome
investors that are
what are his what are his problems well
he can't be on stripe for example so
stripe is our primary payment processor
it's your own stripe account
it's not ours um we get 10
which is the same amount as patreon but
we have a much better product than
patreon because you own all of it you
own the data
you own the users like if you nobody
leaves us but if you leave
it's all yours you can take it with us
if my channel locals has done so well
that if my channel blew up
if youtube just took me out tomorrow man
you talked to pomp you're done
if they took me out tomorrow um my
business is still thriving like i have
for something like 1.6 million
subscribers on youtube i make
way more with my thousands of
subscribers
on patreon so i've built a steady model
to make myself
uncancelable and that's what we then
were like all right now we've got a
business here let's let's
twist what are the responses so i think
there's a lot of people who are
interested in this some of them are
interested because uh they literally
fear
being canceled for what they say yeah
there's people who fear the platforms
are just manipulating things there's
people who fear
that distribution goes away there's
people who fear that they will get
caught up by association
right they interview somebody whatever
uh and then there's literally people who
just fear like
chaos you know i think just like i did
nothing i talked to nobody like i just
have an accountant that
you know it doesn't work either way like
just like something bad happened right
um and you see that you know somebody on
twitter gets suspended and they're like
i haven't even tweeted in three days or
whatever and
usually it's like some stupid thing
where uh
um there's a founder that i invested in
this company uh
there was an event that happened in the
world he started to get a bunch of
followers next you know he's suspended
my guess is that literally there's like
an automated system
it looked like spam to them because it
was like an explosion of followers or
something
get suspended then but the point is you
don't know we don't know the problem but
but still just that stuff can happen or
whatever
so i guess like when you think about all
of that what are the ingredients to be
quote
independent or like to really be
resilient on the internet today so
you first off you have to have direct
access to your audience
that's number one so when i tell you i
have whatever it is 1.6 million youtube
subscribers
i can't get videos out to them because
the algorithm now
they've decided that you're subscribed
this is just what they've decided at
youtube
your subscribers actually have less
weight now so they they're sending you
videos usually now based on your viewing
habits
which by the way can really pigeonhole
you into a certain political
belief or religious belief or whatever
it might be or for me it's just sending
me a lot of 80s basketball and star wars
videos
all day long like i'm watching you use
all my you know you know that that's
really the way to get to know somebody
just
look at their youtube history it's like
man i have watched the 1992 nba season
every game backwards and forwards i
don't watch regular basketball anymore i
can't take it because it's all political
and
whatever um but you you want direct
communication with your audience so what
we built i mean the locals app is
awesome you get push notifications when
i post things
so that's just one like you will get my
stuff we're not manipulating it with an
algorithm
the news feed is unmanipulated so that's
part and it's uh reverse chronological
so if i
sign in the last thing you posted is
first i can kind of go back and just see
and you can assume like a facebook
profile page or something
right and it's uh you can either filter
it if you're in the rubin report
community you can filter it just by what
i'm posting or
we let all our users post and by the way
we're getting something like what's the
number 80
of the content something like 80 of the
content in my
community is from the users not from me
so and what's interesting about that is
they're posting recipes they're posting
music they're posting things about
sports all kinds of stuff
things that they know i like but then
people are sort of coming to social
media in with fresh eyes
because as opposed to you post to pick
your a picture or you post a recipe
you know you make chicken parm you post
it on facebook next thing you know your
grandma's fighting with some random
person
about trump and it's like man this all
became evil and now grandma doesn't seem
as nice as grandma's supposed to be and
i don't know who that person is but oh
it turns out i was
i went to high school with them 20 years
ago and now and but it all feels awful
on there we have people coming there's a
common what i want every locals
community to have and this is what they
all have
is you could just come together for some
common cause so
for a guy like you would be okay i love
bitcoin i believe this is the future of
commerce and
the engine that's gonna lead us to the
new world and then people
are like oh pomp's cool like i'm going
to come into this community we're going
to talk about stuff and then what you're
going to find is they're going to start
talking about a lot of other stuff
so it's it's what social media was
supposed to be and again because of the
paywall
you you get rid of all if you had a 10
cent paywall
as i said on locals ours i think i said
this year i probably started our minimum
is two dollars but if we had a 10 cent
paywall that would eliminate almost all
the bad act
so really what you're doing is you're
basically taking patreon or kind of pay
or
sub stack would be another example all
these kind of paywall based
individual products you're bringing it
all together on one platform you're
saying hey
everything from video to text to audio
whatever
you can basically come and do behind
this paywall in a community
uh you as the individual that owns the
community or
uh as kind of the creator you're the
mayor in essence
and you can then bring everyone together
they all can communicate with each other
they can communicate with you
and it's kumbaya off to the races and
because it's a paywall because people
have to subscribe because they want to
hear from you
it changes the dynamics rather than just
like
you know just mass chaos on twitter yeah
not only does it completely change the
dynamics but you set the rules so if if
in your community let's say you said
like i i made an announcement very early
on i was like listen you guys can say
whatever you want here
you say whatever don't break the laws of
the united states but if you break the
laws of the united states you've got a
bigger problem than me or locals right
so don't break laws the united states
and we don't allow for porn that's
pretty much it
if you want to i have plenty of people
that come in there and they'll be bad
people no porn like
there's enough there's enough people
doing porn online like
only friends i just saw they're trying
to raise it over a billion dollars i
just saw that in forbes it's like jesus
they're doing all right but
but well people were giving me [ __ ]
about it i was just like you know what
like what does it really work yeah like
well because why
dave you're the free speech guy like
porn's free and this is not even me
making a
commentary on porn i was just like
there's enough stuff going on like we
don't need to be in that world and by
the way it also complicates things as
you know with payment processors
and a whole bunch of other stuff so it
was just like you just
you pick what your battles are that's
the problem with being the free speech
guy no
it is well that's the thing so when
people so that's why we did it this way
that speech is left up to you as the
creator that because you're creating
your community
it's like having your rules so you come
into my house
you can't just walk into my house and be
like dave you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] like
then you got to leave my house
so that's how we treat you know like
that's pretty simple but you could say
whatever you want outside of my house
so so we leave it on to you as the
creator
and by doing that i think that that's
the spirit of what
free speech is like i'm not here to go i
can't
you want me to have a policy around hate
speech okay well what's one person's
free speech is someone else's hate
speech
so that's what i think the most related
uh the users that are on there
are politics related versus other things
right and and the reason why i ask this
is um
one of the things that fascinates me is
it's very clear in the political circles
people who think about this a lot who
spend time there
censorship uh deep platforming like it
seems like a lot of that happens there
yeah
now actually maybe it's happened in some
other places right across various
platforms and not just in the united
states and
you know internationally as well so just
like out of curiosity how much of it is
politics-related communities versus
others yeah i don't know that i can give
you an
exact percentage maybe you can um but
what i can tell you is this
i think it's over under fifty percent
politics probably over right it's
probably a little bit over
politician is a combination of a lot of
stuff yeah we talk about politics but we
do have
people talk about nutrition and sport
and nutrition
so yeah so first of all i would first
answer that by saying locals is for
everybody if
you have an interest and you have people
that care about your interest
you should be on location yeah it's very
clear we have it's not even just a
crater if you run a
i have a friend who runs a uh like a
babe ruth baseball league in jersey
it's like he we're on boarding him
because he's got this community he
doesn't want it to be on facebook
anymore because facebook's melting down
and it's like if you have a community of
any knitters unboxers whatever it is
we want you to be on there that's that's
the first part the second part is for
the percentage i'm not
i'm not totally sure but i will tell you
this for sure it's leaning
political because the people who are the
early adopters on this stuff who are
sensitive
about free speech and censorship are in
the political world so it's just
it's a function but i think you'll find
this really interesting which is when we
were raising funds
originally we would go into we went into
every you
whoever is in your head right now in the
catalog of the investors in silicon
valley
we went into every office we never once
i kid you not
heard anyone complain about the tech say
that we had some massive weakness or it
wasn't right
nobody said that the mission wasn't
right everybody loved all of that stuff
when we got nose the nose always came
down to one thing
it's political dave you're thought of as
a little bit right or something
something
we got to be careful you know when this
all changed coven
well a little bit after code but it's
actually connected to covet because
covet
basically we all had a big tech problem
and then what happened because of covert
we all got more obsessed with big tech
it all changed on january 6th
interesting well actually i guess
january 12th or so like four days later
when they blew up the parlor servers
because when amazon blew up the parlor
servers parlor had 23 million people on
there all right
uh because i'm not familiar with all the
details uh parlor was
a app it was basically a twitter clone
that that people that were frustrated
with twitter mostly conservative leaning
people were
were starting parlor they were leaving
twitter and going to this other place
or at least at least being there both
but trying to migrate
okay so there was an effort to go yeah
uh i think you just said that they had
23 million users yeah youtube
numbers huge number and it was it was 23
i mean how many
twitter has 300 million is that right i
think so
which is probably really like seven
people but
let's just say that uh but i should be
clear i really like jack i don't know if
you like jack or not no
no okay all right i mean i've never met
him and i would like to meet him
i like him because of all the bitcoin
stuff and i think he's got a very unique
view of the world and a special
uh he's in a unique seat where he can
have an outsized impact
because of twitter square and like his
view and how important he thinks we can
talk about it later yeah
can i just let me just say one thing
about him which is that he should just
have a different job in my opinion i'm
sure he's a decent person and i know
he's doing good stuff
leading the the bitcoin revolution and
all that but like to me it's like the
the
the twitter part of it where there were
so many important things related
to all the societal stuff that we were
talking about here he just needed to
hand that job to somebody who was more
capable of dealing with those issues did
you
see um i don't know how he got yeah i
don't know how we got to uh
jack but uh he did a
i think he went on first it was jack and
joe rogan
yeah and then he had a conversation and
then
there's a second episode and it's like
tim paul joe rogan jack
and i forget the woman's name but she
runs like yeah or something
yeah kind of policy yeah and it's like
she's he's a lawyer
who's like really into like who gets to
stay who doesn't whatever
i actually took away from that
conversation i think i would listen to
it twice
or yeah i think i listened to your
choice way more complex
than most people give it credit right in
terms of like it's outside oh yeah i
can't believe you guys did this or
whatever
the second thing was like they actually
had some like good
frameworks for how they evaluate how
they get applied you can
debate or whatever and it seemed to me
like the classic example of like jack
twitter and the team is like on one side
like tim paul really was like completely
different and then they kind of like
maybe they didn't meet in the middle but
like they got a lot closer during the
conversation yeah my biggest takeaway
from the whole thing was like
man people who disagree if they just sat
down and talked to each other like the
world would be
so much further ahead it was an
incredible discussion actually all
i would say on that so we don't get too
lost on jack is it just seems to me he
should
probably have some other job that there
they should probably have someone
that's a little more engaged and a
little more i think he takes a step
further
yeah i think he's publicly said that he
nor does he want twitter to be in the
position of
making those decisions like the whole
like but at the end of the day if you
boot
if you boot donald trump and you're the
ceo of the company then
right so okay okay we don't have to get
lost on jack though don't talk [ __ ]
about jack
i'm sure you know like i don't think
he's a bad that's the problem that all
of us in in this public thing are put in
it's like you have to have opinions
about
yeah we have opinions about these things
not have to we have here's the other
thing that i will
say uh that's really fascinating and
maybe jack's actually a pretty good
example
uh humans are really complex yeah
because we live in a complex world
and so in some crazy way uh i bet you
if you ask jack and he may kill me for
saying this
but if you asked him he could probably
with great accuracy
say here's my beliefs on bitcoin here's
my beliefs on free speech here's my
beliefs on twitter it's my beliefs on
square here's my beliefs on whatever
else
and then he could retroactively almost
look at like how everything's played out
at square and twitter
and with bitcoin and like pretty
accurately probably identify i wish we
did this better i think that that
went right i know people didn't like
this idea but i still think that was the
right decision like
and when you do that i think it's um
this interesting thing of uh
it's kind of like with trump when he
first became president
uh i remember saying to a couple people
i don't really know anything about this
guy
but steve schwartzman and all these
folks who
for all intents and purposes seem pretty
intelligent yeah they all keep going in
meetings with them and walking away
and saying like pretty high praise again
they can be full [ __ ] they can actually
be morons never talk to him before you
know like all the stuff yeah
like that's interesting and i think that
a lot of these
uh leaders of these big companies when
you talk to the people who know them
like elon elon was loved in the bitcoin
community now he's like you know
basically everyone's like yelling about
whatever yeah uh
you talk to people who know him and
they're just like dude he's like a dude
like if he came and said
right now being he's just we would all
talk to him and be like you know that
guy's like super scary smart
uh by the way like he probably has a
sixth sense of humor like in some
areas and like he's right i don't think
he's a twitter account right
the takeaway wouldn't be oh he's a dick
or like he's like truly english
so that's i'm honestly i'm not i really
try not to go after people's motives i
actually think it's very possible that
what you're saying there when he took
all of those things that he had in front
of him and how they all map together
but then twitter became something that
no one could have ever
um that's the thing no one could have
ever imagined what these texts
setting up my twitter yeah yeah right
right like said it yeah there you go
like we couldn't have imagined and he
was just the guy that was in charge of
it
and that doesn't make him god or evil
necessarily
so yes when even though i can be
critical of some of the mistakes i mean
trust me you know i'm now partly running
a tech company like
am i going to make mistakes and are
people are going to go on podcasts
saying they don't like dave rubin
they will it's okay i think they've
already said that somebody definitely
said that again
again my twitter mentions are not on so
i wouldn't know i wouldn't know
all right but parlor is where you were
going yeah so
it starts to become popular yeah 23
million users or whatever
let's say that's up five to ten percent
of twitter's audience i think
yeah uh what happened so in essence what
happened was
it was it was all the conservative right
leaning people tons of trump people on
there
and parlor was basically doing no
moderation whatsoever
apparently apple did ask them a couple
times to do some moderation
and they just weren't doing it we had a
couple of conversations with them
because we thought maybe we could work
with them very early on
and it became sort of clear to us that
they were just going to play by their
own rules and
and the truth is even for all of us that
don't like rules there's a system in
places we're talking about and sometimes
you got to play within that system right
you can't just
do everything at once um and apple was
asking them to moderate like
whatever they considered breaking the
law type stuff or
so i think it was well i think they were
doing something a little closer to hate
speech which is always that sort of
amorphous like well what is hate speech
exactly and
can you say this about this protected
group but not about this protection and
all that yeah
but of course they didn't this is you
you live in that world that's right
that's like a world that is
a freaking murky it is something it's uh
i think myself i speak for myself and i
think a lot of people
that i kind of spend time with uh they
like things like
bitcoin or technology or whatever
because it's like it either works
or doesn't like the code either works or
it doesn't or whatever
and when you get into this whole world
of like politics and
and hate speech and like whatever uh i
think there's a lot of things that
people
something may say and they're like yep
that goes in good or bad bucket right
and it's like very obvious
if i say i love you good bucket if i say
you know
the n word at you like all this stuff
then there's stuff that's kind of in
like the gray area and i think that's
kind of what you're getting at is like
it almost then you start asking kind of
like who said it who did they say it too
well that's whatever and that's where i
think a lot of technologists are just
like
uh there's no like yes no there's no one
one or zero right and so like that's
just like a whole different world
well that's why i'm also telling you i
have sympathy for jack you know what i
mean that's why i'm saying
he got involved in something that he did
not intend to get involved in that
became something so massive he could
have
never imagined it so let's just real
quick on like the hate speech part
the supreme court of the united states
says there's no such thing as hate
speech
meaning if you just like there isn't
yeah because you can
if you break the laws of the united
states you're in trouble but you're
allowed to say mean things about people
you can't directly coordinate a violent
terrorist attack
or tell a mob to kill somebody or yell
fire in a crowded theater with the
intent to do harm you actually
people don't know this you actually can
yell fire in a crowded theater in a
funny context
or but if you're doing it to gin up
people that's
with that's with intent and you can't do
it so but the point is beyond those
things and then the very
the almost never used laws around
slander slander and libel
which are pretty much never used because
they're so strict there's no such thing
as hate speech you're allowed to say i
don't like jews i would prefer that
people not say it but you're allowed to
say it you're allowed to say i don't
like black people i don't like gay
people
but you can't say go kill all those
black people or that sort of thing
so the point is we've now asked
technology companies to do
things that the united states government
has decided it can't do so it's like
we're trying to empower them
in some ways to be more powerful so
parlor basically was just like we're not
gonna you do whatever the hell you want
to do on here
then the january 6 capital riots happen
and then really what happened that
nobody's written a proper story on
um is that the answer five or six days
later
was to blow up the parlor servers so
what does that mean so amazon just took
down the parlor servers i don't know
what that you probably know more than me
like i don't know is that a button
is there a button at amazon like you
said blow up i'm saying oh okay
there's something i don't know that's
coming next i think the next version i'm
not kidding actually but the next
version of like this
information war is that they will
literally blow up server farms but
putting aside that for a second right
that's good for the decentralized people
so
we're doing all right um but but i don't
know i honestly don't know like what how
does amazon just shut up i probably just
shut down the
there's an aws like ec2 instance or
whatever like i don't know what you're
doing there it's a button
it depends where they do it they
probably have multiple ways to think of
a server
right but i would like to think it's
something dramatic not just like tapping
a button like it would like to be like
something
that's probably more a button than
physically take over to row seven
in this data center and pull the plug
that actually but that for the movie
version of this seems better you know
bob go in row seven yeah um whose server
is it up
um anyway what happened there when when
amazon did that was a
massive or yeah when amazon did that was
a massive escalation
because this wasn't like kicking off
individual people or kicking off a group
or even kicking off the president of the
united states which was happening at the
exact same time
this was saying this entire network
of 23 million people cannot be online
and subsequently what we've found
out now i mean there's many articles
written about this is that there was far
more coordination
for the january 6 events regardless of
what you think about them far more
coordination on facebook
than on parlor so if anything was
supposed to be blown up if that's what
you think the answer to this was
it should have been facebook not parlor
so in essence what really happened there
was
the tech guys all saw oh that's actual
competition and it's not funded by any
of our people
it's not funded by any of the tech world
people and it was a mafia move it was
just like you can't encroach
you're from jersey mafia you know your
ground
new york you know your ground you can't
play over here and we're just going to
take you out so that's what happened oh
but the reason is
so parlor is back okay it's a little
unclear if they're getting a lot of
traction right now we've had some talks
with them like i want it to succeed
because i love competition and i love
i love just more i want more stuff to be
out there to hopefully make these
products better it's like
if parlor can do something that that is
some feature let's say or something that
twitter's like oh we got to do that well
then maybe they buy them maybe they
build a better feature like that's the
beauty of all of it anyway
after that happened and parlor went down
suddenly
our phones were ringing off the hook
from investors to investors
because everybody was like whoa whoa
whoa something the war just
majorly leveled up like this is not
about booting individual people anymore
now we see like the true power that
these guys have over us
and then fortunately because of that we
got awesome investors and
and the company's growing and are you
able to say so i invested yeah who else
is in that round are you able to say so
david sacks slid around from craft and
he's just been
like extraordinarily awesome he's he's
opened doors for us
and just he really literally in the if
i've learned one thing i'm sure you
have your versions of this in investing
all the people that want to have long
meetings
never invest and they just want to talk
and it's just in retrospect it's
[ __ ] and they're just
mining you for data and hours and
seven follow-up meetings and now talk to
this guy and they just take all your
[ __ ]
the all the people and you included we
literally had like a two-minute
conversation
i i actually don't even think we asked
within like 30 seconds you were like
i want in like let's do this literally
i'm not making that up oh okay you guys
are gonna
uh be resilient all right yeah no that's
you were kind of like i like what you're
doing you're fighting like this is a
mess like let's figure it out
and and saks was like that and balaji
who you mentioned before is in and naval
is in
and uh give me some other names orrin
hoffman's in
and uh christian angermeier and we've
just got like a
he's the mushroom guy um we should start
that by the way
he's the mushroom after the article
christian i love you but after that
article where it was like you know
uh was a german billionaire uh finally
figured out bitcoin on mushrooms like we
should just call the mushroom guy well
i told you right before we started i
don't think he would have a problem me
saying this publicly but i've been we've
become good friends and i've been to
many parties with him
where i always thought he was drunk and
then uh he did my show
we're gonna release it in like a week or
so and he said in the show that he know
he's never had alcohol
never but he's always on you know like a
low dose of mushrooms so he's always got
that look in his eyes and he's smiling
kind of like you right now he's got that
look
he's just happy and like i'm not on
mushrooms
and yet you're still into bitcoin that's
odd yeah uh the other thing he told me
which
was fascinating is he tries his best to
not get on the
autobahn in uh germany because he's
really into longevity and so
yeah car accidents are like the you know
one of the highest reasons why you would
have a shortened lifespan instead one of
my basketball heroes growing up drazen
petrovic from the new jersey nets died
on the autobahn peak of his life
there you go um all right so as we kind
of continue down this road the number
one
question uh that now i think we've been
talking about like an hour and 40
minutes and we
haven't asked you yet everyone wants to
know what do you think about bitcoin
so so that was where this was so we were
talking about
everything else what do you think about
bitcoin this was a hell of a lead-in
that you did there
uh that was amazing um so i honestly
believe this is all the future so i
cannot what does that mean so first off
let me say
i cannot talk about bitcoin at the
technical level that is going to impress
you
at any level whatsoever or any of your
viewers if i
get into any of this like it's it's not
my world and it's a world that i'm just
can you talk to us about the minor
signaling for taproot uh
i can do activation pretty extensive
dissertation on that
specifically um the idea of
decentralized finance
is so connected to everything that we've
talked about here and a bottom-up
economy and that people need the ability
to have
unfettered access to the goods and
services and people
that they want to communicate with
without central banks and without
federal reserve and all of those things
that is where i can sort of do this at
the idea level like this
it's so obviously the answer it's so
obviously the answer
all the specifics on what the best coins
are and all that kind of stuff is not my
thing however i will say
that as we're building on locals like
we're working on all sorts of
decentralized
payments right now and trying to figure
out you know subscription models
with uh with different cryptos which is
extremely complex because obviously the
prices are going up and down and all
that
i have some bitcoin it's locked all
right so you own bitcoin i own bitcoin
all right i have seven bitcoins do you
seven yeah that were all given to me by
the
way
i never i never spent a dime on bitcoin
wait what very very
well because very early on when i left
the patreon thing and i did that
people because a lot of my audience is
libertarians and they were like hey put
a bitcoin wallet up there
and i put a wallet up and people would
give me little bits here and there and i
was just like all right let's see what
happens and this is kind of fun it's
like 300 000
and now i've got seven of them it's on a
ledger and the ledger's in a safe
thing and you know i got the thing and
the thing yeah
you're uh you're further along than most
people
yeah do you remember the first time you
heard about bitcoin
i i think it was it was right when we
left
it's like 2017. so that's like 2016.
2016. very early on because i remember
yeah i do remember
we were leaving patreon and i was i had
a paypal you know a page that you go to
to donate or whatever i think i had a
paypal and maybe that was even before
stripe
and my libertarians that were in my
comment section they were dave
bitcoin bitcoin open a wallet and i
really didn't know what it was but like
but what was cool about it was like i
was like oh well here are these people
who like
whatever it is i'm talking about so i'm
talking about freedom and free speech
and states rights and all of these
things and low taxes and blah blah
and they're all into something so
there's got to be something here
so that was sort of how i kind of
entered this world and now it's like
well now i'm in it because we got a tech
company and i want to solve these
problems
so it's like the stripe thing is really
interesting one again i like patrick
hollis and i think stripe
is a great company and it's been great
for us but like do i want
only people who are on stripe to me on
locals no i do want it to be
more open than that so it's less about
get off straight and it's more about
stripe plus other options yeah
i want to have diversification across
payment channels and almost let people
choose what payment channel do you want
to use
can i say that because that's what i
want yes all right i got clearance i got
clearance from the big man
um no well that's that's more esop's
world but uh
but yes we want as many options out
there
because otherwise the choke points you
know what's what's accepted to be said
at least at this time in america is
going to continue to be like this
from a mainstream perspective so you
want as many options when it comes to
payments
we want as many options when it comes to
servers right we don't want
you know amazon to blow us up or this or
that other thing i probably can't talk
about all that we're working on on that
front because
just for security reasons you know what
i mean but like you want to create
something that is
as or not you well you i think yes but
like i want to create something
that is as free and accessible and
decent and neutral as is humanly
possible
when you think of bitcoin and um
kind of that entire world that entire
audience are there things that
you see that kind of align from
how you think about the political
standpoint the free speech uh
other nation states like it just feels
like bitcoin is such a natural thing
given everything else that you talk
about you think about all day long
um are you surprised that maybe like
more people in that world haven't
flocked to bitcoin or kind of embraced
it or is there like some sort of like
obstacle in terms of it's a technology
thing and
that's just a that's different or yeah
um well on the purely ideological part
as i said it fits because most of my
audiences they're not necessarily like
hard carrying libertarians but like they
get
like there's a philosophical line right
so the philosophical part is there i
would say for a
certain part this would probably be like
sort of like my parents like
there's like this other piece of like
what do you mean it's not backed by
something or it's bad but it's all on
computers or they're minors but what are
they mining where are the minds like
all of that kind of stuff getting a
certain person and that's what
it's so that's actually so consistent
with what's going on in the world right
now like
everything is changing and then because
of social media it's changing so fast
that it's like it's really hard to say
to somebody that like put all their
money
in stocks and bonds and you know i put
all this money into my ira all these
years and all that like even when i was
talking to my
business managers a few months ago as
we're doing you know planning
and my guy's like you know i want you to
put x amount in your ira
every year for the next blah blah and
then you're going to have this and you
know
and i'm thinking well hey like does that
mean
exactly but that's not a thought that
someone really would have had 10 years
ago the belief that the system itself
would keep marching along no matter what
was there but you know if you talk to
somebody in greece
as they watched all of their money
disappear and going to the atm
you know you're getting you know no
drachmas are showing up or
when they do they're they're worth
nothing it's like
that piece of it it's like for all the
reasons that i went independent in terms
of my content
i want to be free be on my on the
economic side as well
yeah it's fascinating that there's not a
piece of technology that embodies so
much of this
yeah and as people learn about it
they're like oh yeah like of course
that's gonna be a thing but that's why
it's so cool so like
i think the way i came across you was
somebody retweeted you into my feed
something about bitcoin and then it's
like all right
you know you know how twitter works and
suddenly you click on somebody's profile
you're quickly kind of looking around
and it's like you were not talking about
politics per se but it was just obvious
that the way you look at the world is
similar to the way that i look at the
world and again i don't know what all
your political beliefs are and it's
completely irrelevant to me
if we if we i think we're going out to
dinner after it's like we go out to
dinner we're
knocking back tequila and then it turns
out we disagree on every policy
it would be irrelevant you know what i
mean it would be like utterly irrelevant
you're a good guy you care about what
you're doing like i like people who are
doing things
and passionate and you know all that
stuff you you've said multiple times
about somebody they're decent
they're decent humans and i i actually
think uh well it's somewhat of an
elementary pursuit
well it's like an elementary term but
it's actually like
a pretty good bar right of because you
can disagree with somebody on everything
but you know what decent person yeah
like that's actually like a good way of
viewing
are they a good person or not like are
they decent just
decent like are you just decent like not
you get everything right not that you're
so spectacular not that you're really
great anything
but like are you just a d you know and
you know it when you're with someone you
know is this a decent person or not a
decent person that's like
and it's sort of like uh you know people
say um
you know what is what is porn well
you'll know it when you see it sort of
thing and that's kind of like
a decent person but but anyway that's
why i think what's happening right now
and why i'm so
excited to move locals down here and be
here right now and just like be part of
what's going on in miami it's like
and the fact that i'm going to talk to
the the mayor who's retweeting me left
and right now thanks to you it's like
it's like whoa there's a new world on
the horizon like it is
it is the um you know what do you call
it
it is that synth wave future that the
libertarians want and i love those
colors that color scheme
like and i've always and i love
dystopian movies and i love like
all of that future stuff but we have a
chance to really build it right now we
really do
and there's a lot of people who are just
holding on and they're holding on and
you can in some ways you can't blame
them it's sort of like we were like the
jack thing in a way it's like
you can't blame people who are seeing
something in a certain way when the
world was set up in one way for such a
long time
like i can't blame my dad yeah
if i could get jack to sit down with you
would you sit down of course of course
yeah he had agreed a few times with his
pr people and then it just never came
through now i've
i've gone after him pretty hard on on
twitter i would have
i would have i promise you if you can
set it up i will have no problem
starting the conversation by saying i i
apologize for anything that i said
i cannot make any promises at all uh
that would be like a pretty
out of left field thing but uh let me
see that i would be interested to see
you two sit down and have a conversation
i would
i would i would learn from both of you i
think you you could moderate it
you could not accept the rules but no
you can't but
but i honestly if if you can tell him
when you started off with you get
moderated and set the rules i'm out
you're a decent guy you're a decent guy
jack's decent two jacks needs it too
all right three three decent guys yeah
all right all right i asked the same
three questions everyone before i finish
up you get asked me once again
uh most important book you ever read
most important you know i've read so
many books in the last so one thing when
i
started the show i used to read every
book every book from a guest
every single one and then just life got
busier and i just can't do it anymore
um this is going to sound a little
cliche but
not only because i was on tour with him
but 12 rules for life really changed my
life really like if you read that book
and you put those ideas into practice
whether it's standing up straight with
your shoulders back telling the truth
like he's laying out the things that if
you do these things
i saw this guy freaking change the world
and and in the course of changing the
world he changed my life so
that's that's a great uh simple yet
powerful
uh book sleep schedule
our friends that ate sleep yeah who now
i've invested i begged them to invest
they finally let me invest and now i
feel like i can really ask this
question people to invest uh these guys
listen they
uh they have a mattress that uh i used
to think like five or six hours like
literally i think
uh one time i told my uh girlfriend at
the time now wife
uh wolves don't sleep she was like the
wolves don't sleep right she was like
you're an idiot
yeah and i was probably uh now i see
like eight or nine hours completely
changed my life and when i sleep on this
uh you can make it hot or cold i sleep
on it like it's like ice cubes yeah i
like it and
uh their ultimate goal is to take eight
hours of sleep compress it down to six
but you get the same amount of deep
sleep and therefore it's like better or
whatever
wait what's it called eight sleep okay i
need to know about eight hours
yeah genius uh marketing yeah what is
your sleep schedule
now and then what was it like through
the years and how does that evolve oh
it's a great question so
i i hugely i believe in you need sleep
especially
when you're just doing stuff with your
brain all day long and talking all day
long and listening all day long
and that's not to diminish people that
are just doing things with their hands
all day that may seem trivial but but
are not actually
um i basically go to sleep
usually about 11 30 or so okay
um i wake up about six i'm very
functional in the morning if i wake up i
have coffee and i just work work work
work work
and then at some point it's like four
o'clock and i'm like whoa i should just
like breathe for a sec sometimes i
forgot to have lunch i've done five
shows you know
that kind of stuff um i really do like
taking a 20-minute nap if i can
around three o'clock if i can just
siesta little siesta or just literally
it's not even a nap like i'm sleeping
but it's literally just close my eyes
for 20 minutes
and just like let myself reset um i
think is absolutely key
um i'm not the greatest sleeper though
so i am interested in this
six and a half hours is not a lot yeah
yeah you should try to get eight
because you go to sleep at night is
there some sort of company you've
invested in that maybe could help me in
this department
is that we'll work on it all right
aliens
believer or non-believer
i could give you a couple couple answers
here what do you know that we all know
yes there is there is other life
out there okay why because i think there
just has to be
like well look there's a beautiful way
to say no to it the beautiful way is
know that
this thing that we're doing right now in
our existence here is so unique and so
special and the
the majestic magical cosmos that put the
earth so close to the sun
and all the elements were right that it
was all just like this magical
incredible god-like event that
and then we're here and it's just us and
like that's actually rare and precious
and beautiful and i actually love that
answer the other part of me that is
is most of me is just like we're here
there's got to be some other stuff out
there and over
over time we we will find that i would
direct people to watch the movie contact
by carl sagan
and it's something like that if you had
to chew this as a fourth question i'm
cheating
uh if you had to choose are you more
worried about what's in the ocean or
what's in space
would you rather go to the depths of the
ocean or go to space yourself
um i well personally which would i like
to go to
yeah space like i just love sci-fi stuff
and like all right you know star wars
like defined my life for so long before
they ruined it and like
there's something about the depths of
the ocean you like the depths of the
ocean no i'm out
if i put you in like a submarine and i'm
just like all right we're gonna send you
down like two miles and then no good i'm
out
it's it doesn't seem possible really you
know well and then like you like see
things that like you're like
i didn't even know that was an animal
like you ever seen like some of these
videos you're like uh what
no they just changed colors like it just
moved [ __ ] like i
i don't know but are those aliens that's
always a question that's a good question
always a question
i don't know all right well one question
yeah i get to ask you a question that's
a good one i was thinking about it this
is like the scariest thing in the world
is letting you ask me a question
yeah all right all right
all right and the more you think about
it the more nervous i can
well i think you you've addressed this a
little bit but i think it's the right
it's the question that would be on my
mind to ask you the most all right
which is what do you really think is
going on with elon and bitcoin
oh um is that too cliche no no no no no
no uh
i think everyone's overthinking it i i
literally think that uh
let let me address all of it as kind of
uh um
on like a grand scale yeah can i add one
sentence in first here's the layman's
version because i
saw him pumping it up we're gonna and
again this isn't totally my world
he's pumping it up we're taking it for
tesla blah blah blah then he goes on snl
which is like a mainstream airlock
moment for him
there's all the controversy around that
and then you know in essence five days
later
you know we're out so that all just in
my world the way i pieced it very chaos
just feels very chaotic and and also
oddly coordinated and whatever
yeah so um
i always want to assignment though he's
a very decent guy
like ignorance not malice in a lot of
situations i
literally go back to you don't have a
master plan i don't have a master plan i
don't think elon has a master plan
like yes he is the most or second or
third most rich
uh person in the world i literally don't
think he thinks of him that way right i
don't think he likes you wakes up and
he's like you know what
the richest guy in the world like screw
you guys right right i just don't think
that like you get to that point and
that's how you think every day
maybe i'm wrong the second thing is uh
i think that he is a
um rational economic actor
from the sense of he saw an asset that
he believed could be valuable
uh he had capital he bought some of it
he said hey you guys can pay me some of
it not that many people i think zero or
one cars for about bitcoin like
less than five for sure and that's
surprising though
well i mean it's an intelligence test am
i going to am i going to spend
bitcoin right right if i own bitcoin i
think it's going to go
you know higher in us value over time
and buy a car like okay
so like counter-intuitive at first when
you think about it like okay make sense
why no one
okay then the
second aspect is they sold bitcoin 10
of their stake they tested liquidity of
the market
um happened that they could really beat
on an earnings report and like there's
always like components
to it and i just say all of us have all
these conspiracy theories
throw them all out the window i
literally think he's having fun
which you can argue good bad hurting
people helping people like like there's
all these ramifications of it
forget all the ramifications for a
second what drives the tweet
every time he talks positive or negative
i literally think he's like the rest of
us
we grab our phone and we're like i gotta
watch this
rips the tweet yeah yeah and sometimes
he's
people are attacking him and he's like
you know i'm gonna stick it to the
bitcoiners and he fires off a dogecoin
tweet
yeah and then sometimes he's like all
giddy and he
i really believe in bitcoin you know i
mean that would be kind of psycho
stuff though if you knew you could have
that much influence on people's lives
and like the course
i think you i him and anyone with a big
account
completely forget and are com
not oblivious oblivious would be too
strong of a word uh we drastically
underestimate the impact
like i when i tweet i forget that there
are a
million people right so it's the
accidental psycho sort of
that's something i think in some crazy
way we're all
regardless of what we want to say we all
want to like virtue super big oh i'm not
addicted whatever like
how many times you pick up your phone if
you go on apple you can look it up like
one time i looked
i never want to look again like there's
a lot of things that i would rather do
to never look at my
uh how many times people you know i do
off the grid august where i lock my
phone and say for a month wait what does
that mean my fifth year doing it okay
i literally i did it as a test four
years ago and i okay
literally lock my phone into safe my
computer my ipad no nothing i do no news
i do no really no current events
i don't even go to the gym because they
have tvs everywhere and
then i come back on the grid and i've
had uh ben shapiro did it with me once
glenn beck
michael knows couple other guys we do it
live where they fill me in on
everything that i've missed and i watch
no tv nothing electronic
what's the craziest thing that happened
while you were gone well you think that
crazy
like one year john mccain died one year
well last year the big thing was that
the song whap came out that seemed to be
the biggest
and i guess what's her name is that
rihanna no
great song her pussy's dripping i don't
know whatever she's got a bucket or
something but
uh no you realize very quickly that
actually
it's okay you know like yeah some stuff
the republicans voted on this and
they're up yeah something blew up in
lebanon or something and like and it's
just like the world goes on but i find
it
just like you know working on the whole
month that's great yeah
go lay out on the beach stare at this
off the grid
august yeah wow i'm going to challenge
some people publicly i know you can't do
a month but maybe can i get you on a
weekend
you think you could do i could do a
weekend you can do a weekend you want
you want to hear actually sounded
pretty crazy um it's happened twice so
three years ago or so i took two weeks
off i cheated a little bit like i would
still go on twitter and read a little
bit yeah
uh but i didn't tweet and i really
really stayed off and
i always joked that i knew that it was
working because uh multiple times when i
was living in new york
my wife and i would go for a run and i
would leave my phone behind which would
be blasphemous
you know any other time and uh i didn't
care
he'd call me whatever i just don't care
right uh and the second time was uh when
i went to iraq and i came back i didn't
have a cell phone for a year
and i was young you know 21 or whatever
uh when i came back
and i remember wait did you serve in
iraq oh yeah oh wow yeah i didn't know
that oh i got lots of thoughts
let's not go there yeah wow uh and so
when i came back
i just didn't care like like i didn't
have to have it
with me all the time or whatever and so
it was like this really interesting
thing of just like we are all addicted
we all say we're not whatever when you
wake up you grab your phone when you
walk into the room you go on your
computer like whether it's email phone
calls
social media whatever like we are all
addicted can i give you one that maybe
your
your mattress guys can work in with some
kind of promotion
don't bring your phone in your bedroom
yeah i don't do it i actually leave it
outside the bedroom i usually leave it
in the kitchen
but the last thing that you do before
you go to bed should not be
scrolling to doom scrolling twitter or
you know just like that
you know infinity scrolling until your
mind is turning into scrambled eggs
and the first thing that you do in the
morning should not be whether it's just
email yep
it just should not be that yeah like it
should not be and yet almost
everyone before you freaking pee in the
morning which is really what you have to
do
yep you do this thing so i really really
try not to have this in my bedroom
very rarely does this ever happen um but
there's been a couple times i've woken
up to text messages
and usually it's like some catastrophic
i put the narrow quotes right some
catastrophic event happened with like a
founder that we've invested or something
and they're freaking out and you notice
like i woke up i was like
pretty chilling yeah i got my eight nine
hours on the eighth sleeve and then it
literally is like i just got whacked by
an 18-wheeler
game on yeah and you're like okay here
we go and
there is this element of like if you can
avoid that like i do think it's better
for you yeah well i don't do it i'm
horrible i don't listen to my own advice
but like i do i do agree with that so
that's my challenge to you all right i
got to ask you a question now i added
something to the podcast
we are not going to spread it challenge
me no no i like that for now on all you
guys have to challenge you with
something which is
just uh whatever on the weekends no
phone you know the first thing people
are going to challenge me they're going
to start bringing me all their coins and
telling me to buy it
that's like i already know where that is
i've seen your mention because i know
what's going on
i've seen your mentions more than i see
my mentions that's yeah all right where
can we send people i feel like everyone
knows where you are but we're gonna send
people on the internet i'm not gonna
send them to big tech go to
rubenreport.locals.com
reubenreport.locals.com and you can
create an account locals account for
free and you can look around see what's
what and if you want to interact then
it costs a couple bucks but i i promise
you it will be worth it but if you just
want to see what's what
and we're building out some incredibly
cool stuff and uh
we're gonna we're gonna save the world
locals we're gonna save the world i like
that that you're you were like well i i
did invest i'm a podcaster i have to be
honest here you know this is not
uh something that i'm keeping quiet you
know it's good
yeah well whatever i just told truth
tell the truth all right
reubenreport.logos.com
that's it thank you so much for doing
this thanks man